le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
l'électronique recycling association aha
qui est un organisme à but non lucratif
dont on vous a déjà parlé ici sur le
sans fil podcast ce qu'ils font eux
c'est qu'ils prennent votre vieux
matériel électronique
il renie pas et il donne à des gens dans
le besoin en ce moment la plupart des
cours sont faits à distance la plupart
des travail des travaux en fait sont
sont à la maison
donc vous avez plus que jamais besoin
d'appareil électronique qui fonctionne
et c'est pas tout le monde qui a su luxe
le si vous vous avez du vieux matériel
électronique en mai maison que vous
voulez vous débarrasser
aimez vous avez peur de le faire ce que
vous voulez pas que vous donnez suivre
le font parce qu'on met de tous sur nos
cellulaires
vous savez de quoi je parle des lectures
et comme chaque langue associations
s'organisent pour faire pour détruire
physiquement elle est donnée donc vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous inquiéter de
ce et c'est parfait pour donner au
suivant
la deuxième vague bat son plein puis des
gens ce moment qui se retrouve dans une
situation très précaire qui auraient
besoin de soutien donc pensez y si vous
avez une cueillette à planifier vous
appelez au 1 8 7 7 9 3 9 2 7 8 3 ou
sinon vous pouvez leur écrire ou aller
sur leur site web pardon triple w point
m à points
c'est avec merci la grande et rare pièce
à l'épisode de cette semaine est
également présentée par nos amis chez
pâli slip
vous savez la saison des cadeaux du
temps des fêtes arrive à grands pas et
quel meilleur cadeau qu'un oreiller
police liban puis moi on dort sur les
oripeaux les slips on ne jure que de ça
vous l'agrandir la ratisser selon vos
préférences de sommeil puis écoutez
c'est parfait pour mettre en dessous du
sapin de noël ou pour envoyer à distance
si comme moi vous faites un échange à
distance parce que noël est un petit peu
quand ces listes années l'on va se dire
les vraies choses
donc si vous voulez envoyer ça à des
gens
c'est un cadeau parfait également durant
le mois de décembre pour les slips à
chaque matelots vendus ils vont poser
cinq arbres donc c'est une super belle
façon aussi d'encourager l'environnement
d'encourager les entreprises d'ici
québécoise qui qui met la main à la pâte
en fait pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques
donc on a un code promo pour vous en
faites qui se trouve à être dsf 25 pour
25 % de rabais sur tous exceptés les
sommiers et ce code promo là est valide
jusqu'au 22 honnêtement un pour noël
cette année offrez vous le cadeau d'un
bon chemin
27e tagline que je viens d'inventer ces
badges de retard hier marketing merci
possible production du f meriaux sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités date seach ph
quentin avec moi d'une plante
vous savez que le studio s'est faite en
location donc si vous voulez partir
votre propre projet de podcasts on loue
le studio on approche maintenant la
pleine capacité ni qu'elle y travaille à
peu près 55 heures par semaine mais il
reste encore la place donc si vous
voulez partir votre propos cas soit mené
lui que vous avez un autre niveau
ne tardez pas écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast at gmail.com il peut le faire au
moins 80 90 la semaine facile quand même
pas les chaînes ils font même pas encore
mal aux pieds le mot de toute façon je
vis ici fait qu'il exauce pourrait être
cette semaine un podcast
particulièrement fascinante toujours
vraiment tellement enrichissante de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui tue sommité
dans son domaine est comme lui dans le
titre sonia lupien qui est chercheur en
neurosciences qui est une spécialiste
incontesté à une sommité dans les études
sur de stress en fête a connu tout tout
sur le stress et
c'est quoi le stress pourquoi envie de
stress comment deal avec le stress que
sont les causes du stress certains
pourraient dire que le stress n'a pas de
secret pour elle ok ça qui justement
c'est le stress on en vit tous c'est
normal il faut apprendre à dealé avec
l'accepter à l'apprivoiser parce que
c'est pas que négatif le stress est ce
qu'on vous est ce que vous allez
découvrir dans le podcast
ce beau livre pour l'amour du par amour
du stress pardon une nouvelle édition
revue et augmentée une nouvelle édition
2020 avec les plus récentes données
scientifiques alors qu'ici on ipodah
l'ésotérisme et l'est où vous c'est
vraiment le goût view
on est vraiment dans la science mais ses
six passes je pense important même pas
ce qu'était capital capitale de savoir
comment dit nino stress parce que ça
nous affecte tous puis surtout en ces
temps troublés en ces temps difficiles
c'est pas seulement important de savoir
gérer ce stress alors mais on ne serait
ajouté mais en fait on n'a pas rien à
ajouter à part que c'est un réel plaisir
des foyers pas de k-swiss cas où est ce
que la conversation passe comme un
claquement de doigts puis c'était le cas
avec sonia aujourd'hui si vous aimez la
conversation évidemment commenté
commenté on peut pas vous demander de
commenter à 6 fait commenté plus encore
participer inconscient on vous lit on
répond pas tout le monde donc vous lis
définitivement le site tmz hors des
rings parlez-en à vos amis vous savez
tous le chacha fait que sans plus
attendre bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
1,3 go 1 2 3 go
merci beaucoup d'être le lendemain tout
le monde en parle
oui pourquoi pas très content de voir si
ce constat ambiante et on s'était par
livre une couple de semaines de voir
qu'est la veille de notre rencontre ça
partage le fait que c'était plaisant
oui c'était super le fun ou pas trop pas
trop stressant vous savez j'avais abordé
beaucoup l'été le climax une non mais je
parlais plus de la gagne et on n'en a
pas fait une petite part et vous ça vous
avez parlé beaucoup de la situation
actuelle avec les imagine le stress qui
monte pour tout le monde dit personne
s'exclut de ce stress collectif le loin
de là puis on va en parler tantôt mais
j'aimerais initialement qu'on parle de
stress en général parce que j'entends je
t'entends d en parler dans plusieurs
conférences ou entrevue que tu as fait
qu'ils sont disponibles en ligne
puis c'est fascinant que ce soit une
réaction du corps à des stimuli externes
qui sont là depuis tellement longtemps
le fait que le stress initialement à
quoi ça soit pour quoi
pourquoi on y est resté en vie moi ça
c'est une mauvaise de bonnes premières
questions parce que je dis tout le temps
les gens sont terrorisés par le stress
et je le redis oubliez pas le cerveau il
est pas mal plus parce qu'on pense que
je dis tout est en jeu on a peur du
stress mais pensez vous sincèrement que
le cerveau aurait créé et le stress pour
nous écrire mon québécois comme je
savais que je mérite de me bourdon
si le stress existe c'est que ça sert à
quelque chose lui à chaque fois qui fait
quelque chose et ça sert à survivre donc
on n'aurait jamais survécu à quoi que ce
soit on serait capable de survivre à la
coved si on n'était pas très sécurisé
aux gens depuis le 14 mars à tous les
matins qu'on se lève toute la gang ont
ni stressés pourquoi parce que le
cerveau fait sa job il détecte une
menace donc comme un show pour assurer
la survie quand je te cerveau
il faut d'abord que je sois capable de
détecter des menaces puis on va voir
peut-être plus tard que c'est possible
que ce soit
et quand il détecte une menace eh bien
il va produire va activer le système bbb
compliqué ce prêt portant qui va faire
en sorte qu'au bout
on va produire des hormones de stress
hockey et ses hormones de stress là vont
nous permettre de faire les deux seules
choses qu'on peut faire si on veut
survivre à la menace combattre ou fuir
son le tout a pris au sérieux
moi je veux continuer l'histoire dans
les deux corps que tu décides de
combattre ou de fuir tant besoin d'une
seule chose d'énergie et ce sont ces
hormones de stress là qui nous donne qui
nous ont donné l'énergie bien mon fameux
mammouth d'antan du mammouth pour soi
tuer la bête la manger il surveille vous
partir à courir et nous voici ayant
survécu au bas mot dont c'est bénin
portable comprend 10 au titre pour ça
que quand on est stressé on est tendu on
est on est six fois plus fort qu'à
l'habitude
c'était déjà essayé de séparer de tout
petits dans une cour d'école qui se
battaient le toit du royaume
stressé et c'est ce qui va faire qu'on
va être capable de générer cette réponse
de stress l'aube ce qu'ils font dans
science parce que nous dans notre labo
c'est rare que je vais utiliser des
questionnaires pour vous demander si
vous êtes stressé vous avez même pas
même définition là qu'on mesure ces
hormones de stress le avant on les
mesure étant ça mais ça marche après
notre affaire parce que suffisent à t-il
que j'arrive avec une seringue tout le
monde se mette à stresser j'avais même
pas commencé ce n'est pas très pratique
là qu'aujourd'hui on peut mesurer sur
dans la salive mon jugement specter que
j'appelle le chef a craché le monde peut
mesurer sa dans les cheveux puis ce
qu'ils font dans les cheveux c'est que
les hormones de stress s'accumulent dans
les cheveux et les cheveux poussent en
moyenne 1 cm par mois taxi je prends
trois centimètres de tes cheveux à
partir de la racine
j'ai trois mois de votre stress et je
peux mesurer dans la transpiration doit
peu près n'importe quoi finances succès
quoi l'unité de mesure dessous se dire
la sorbonne qu'on va montrer
il ya deux types d'hormones a dit ce
qu'on appelle les catécholamines
l'adrénaline la noradrénaline et il ya
les glucocorticoïdes ok cortisol qu'on
va appeler chez l'humain moi j'ai passé
à peu près toute ma carrière à
travailler sur le bugue aux corticoïdes
le cortisol pourquoi parce que
contrairement l'adrénaline l'adrénaline
et un ciel qui dit que tu es stressé
maintenant je mène à mon labo plus de
stress plus j'ai dit ok sur une échelle
de 1 à 10 à quel point tu était stressé
tout neuf josé rochus comment tu suis
sûr que tu t'es fier qu'à un coût de la
cam des badges sur l'adrénaline c'est
elle qui d'elio déstresser mais le
cortisol lui c'est l'espion lui tu sais
pas quand les produits mais lui ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'à l'intérieur
une période de 8 à 10 minutes après
qu'il soit produit il remonte à ton
cerveau l'adrénaline assez long avec
armes ont depuis un même élan lui
remonte directement puis kayak c'est de
ton cerveau ya une préférence marquée
pour les régions comme disait qu'ils
sont impliqués dans l'apprentissage la
mémoire commandes soit incapable de
contrôler tes émotions ici là ça me
prend dans les années 1970 qui ont
trouvé ça et c'est là que c'est devenu
intéressant parce qu'on s'y turquie
c'est comme ça que le stress peut être
associée à l'anxiété des pressions bla
bla parce que il faut pas que ça joue
dans le cerveau le cependant le fois que
ça se développe un autre et donc celle à
qui ça d'ici là que ça va aller jouer
donc c'est pour ça qu'on les mesure puis
si tu en as beaucoup depuis six mois bo
très coûteux et quelque chose qui marche
pas ces censeurs parce qu'en fait avant
de traiter d' écouter des conférences
puis 10e je savais même pas que le
stress était une hormone le type c'était
vraiment calculé jib les immenses
mesurables dans le car je pensais
c'était quelque chose
ces matériels l'enquêté ces récents mais
on sait pas trop de sa vie mais c'est
vraiment facile de voir finalement de
mesurer le stress chez quelqu'un devait
aller plus loin je donne un exemple
quelque chose d'intéressant si tu prends
des patients déprimés qui mesurent leurs
hormones de stress et un autre au hockey
donc devons être en hyper production
d'hormones de stress
si tu prends quelqu'un qui borde la donc
un épuisement professionnel et on a pu à
c'est comme si un jour le corps se
levait pittsburgh pour moi je t'écris
j'en veux plus fatigués souvent les
métiers mon dire que le beurre nantes eu
la même chose que la dépression nous en
sciences du stress on n'est qu'à un pas
du tout de ces deux phénomènes
complètement différent un moment donné
le corps décide de se mettre à chaque
danse comme n'ai plus rien versus dans
l'autre continent produire beaucoup
c'est ce qui va et d'éventuellement
faire des diagnostics différentiels
entre les deux facs pas fait de traire
ses pommiers il faut comme trouver le
sweet spot de stress dans le fond ouais
je me suis bien content de parler à des
jeunes que je me dis si peuvent la
prendre avant est ce que je dis toujours
aux jeunes
arrêtez d'avoir peur du stress parce que
c'est ce qui va vous tuer à long terme
en 2d c'est l'impuissance est de notre
faute à nous ainsi la faute je fais mon
mea culpa c'est la faute des chercheurs
scientifiques et des médias qui depuis
que vous êtes né vont vous dire que le
stress est négatif toxiques faut
l'éviter à tout prix
c'est une erreur d'avoir fait ça
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une courbe en u
inversé dont prendre un pv cette barre
le stress et la performance donc un peu
de stress c'est super bon ça va
augmenter sa vigilance
c'est la première fois que ma fille a eu
une entrevue pour une job on jasait a
atteint pme cotées partie ma soeur a du
coup dont il l'a stressé j'ai dit c'est
que ça change
mais certains niveaux de résistance donc
on a tous un point de résistance qui
différents lots ont tous ses effets
négatifs donc si tu as peur du stress à
temps plein soit retrouvé tout est un
côté négatif peu exploré les deux ont en
effet dû supporter des compétitions puis
justement aval avant le départ nous ne
sommes plus stressés c'est sûr ça vaut
avoir un effet positif sur ta
performance mais les fois où est-ce que
tu allais pas stressé sa marque full
métro streiff et non plus de 10 ou 20 il
ya deux catégories de gens qui savent ce
dont je parle les athlètes parce que
vous l'avez maximiser où tu peux
maximiser la performance en étant un peu
stressé et les artistes
et moi je me suis un artiste m avait dit
six mois une fois dans ma vie où j'ai
pas eu le trac avant une pièce de
théâtre du dépôt chobot tous les actifs
doit vraiment besoin de ça mes autres on
pense aussi pourquoi il ya autant
d'anxiété chez les jeunes de nous dans
nos élus nos écoles c'est ce qu'on
appelle la sensibilité à l'anxiété ce
que je m'explique que vous allez vous
allez reconnaître c'est quoi c'est un
peu comme la part des titres et si tant
qu'artiste récit je te le dis ton corps
est en voie des signes comme toi tu es
stressé dont carbon vie est et c'est
comme portefeuille ou allume il est
choqué pour une raison qu'on savait pas
trop il ya des gens quand ils reçoivent
ce message le ils capotent personnes à
un chevreuil pris dans les phares d'une
voiture qui arrive à vive allure
ça fait quoi faire et on sait pas trop
pourquoi ces gens le paniquer comme ça
devant le stress est une des raisons
c'est qu'on se rencontre on dit qu'une
épidémie nexium d'anxiété dans les
écoles cge ce point une des raisons
c'est sais pas quel âge vous avez le
mais depuis cette nuit sur vos réseaux
sociaux n'importe où on vous dit que le
stress est toxique pour l'éviter et
ensuite on s'étonne que quand un petit
prout qui ne répondent normal de stress
devant un examen et capotes parce qu'il
s'inquiète stressé de siège avec ce
sacre a lancé une en or plus le la peur
la peur du stress mais ce qu'on se l'est
fait
en anglais ça s'appelle des stress
mindset pilotes on se dit les jeunes
faut changer les secours assistés des
prêts conception de stress on regarde
bien les athlètes êtes vous le savez il
chercheur au prix de deux groupes de
jeunes des gens qui ont des prêts
conception négative de stress yvan
terrasse jamais bon du stress sur les
malades qui des gens qui ont des prêts
conceptions politiques et artistiques
dans certains cas c'est bon je mesure
les hormones de stress de ces deux
groupes là les gens qui ont des prêts
conception de stress produisent plus
d'hormone de stress que ceux qui ont des
prêts conception positive
ensuite ils ont pris des gens qui
avaient des prêts conception négative et
pendant une semaine ils leur ont montré
des vidéos des effets positifs du stress
qu ils ont été capables de diminuer en
blanc et alain verte qui ont pris des
gens qui avaient des prix conception
positive et pendant une semaine leur ont
montré des vidéos des effets toxiques et
les gatti lui et on monte les hormones
de stress et c'est pour ça que ce qu'on
dit ça je suis venu aujourd'hui je ne
dirais pas de le dire tout ce qu'on dit
aux cinq années
[Rires]
mais si je capable de leur dire ça de
dire ok la journée où tu vas comprendre
que le stress est que tout ce que tu
peux maximiser comme performance une
fois que tu lis et puis t'as pas besoin
d'être un athlète nécessairement pour le
faire des jaloux tu vas arrêter de
capote avec ça je suis tellement à fort
impact dans la conversation le c'est
fascinant
jusqu'à ce que tu veux dire que l'espèce
de démonisation du stress c'est quelque
chose qui est omniprésent sur les
réseaux sociaux en ce moment l espèce de
ultra c'est pas nécessairement cf caire
mais tns l'espèce dont on enlève tous
les tous les hits récents notre ville
pour se recentrer sur nous mêmes
puis ça en fait c'est un peu une c'est
un peu un service yeux j'imagine parce
que comme tulle explique si t'as pas à
ce point-là du stress créé encore plus
d'anxiété par rapport à lustrer ce
potentiel le ca deviens qui tu commences
à paralyser de vendée a fortement
c'est exactement ce que c'est pour ça
que mon fils mon livre s'appelle par
amour du stress les gens des fois il
disait faudrait et 10 pour coter parce
que quand tu comprends exactement
comment fonctionne la bête
c'est somme toute assez facile à
contrôler oui mais je pense qu on
stresse beaucoup parce qu'on sait pas
comment cas fonction depuis tout à
prouver ça je veux te ramener une notion
que qui s'appelle un stress relatif l'un
quand on parle de stress juste pour
finir mon dico de stress mais sinon on
va se perdre dans quelque chose là une
dernière notion qu'il faut prendre en
compte c'est la différence entre je me
dis qu'un cerveau détecte une menace
produit des hormones de stress
jin jing ses répliques sauf que deux
types de menaces il ya des menaces qu'on
appelle absolue c'est à dire une menace
réelle à notre survie quelques heures
entre et s'ils crient au feu ou comment
ce repos agents ne plus belles baies de
deux semaines la coved cpnsp aux menaces
absolue et on est entourés de nos jours
de menaces relatives c'est symbolique et
les chercheurs se sont retrouvés pris
devant les problèmes et on dit coudonc
je prends deux personnes
systématiquement et j'en ai stressé du
monde dans mon la poule
il prend deux personnes qui était exposé
à la même situation stressante
systématiquement nom qui va réagir avec
une réponse de stress pilotes rien
pantoute
ça existe pour une situation stressante
pour tout le monde à moins que ça soit
menaçante assurland et donc les
chercheurs se sont dit ok mais il doit
avoir des caractéristiques d'une
situation qui vont faire que peu importe
qui tu es large que tout la job que toi
tu as très sion chercher ça pendant 20
ans et ils sont arrivés à découvrir les
quatre caractéristiques dont je parle
tout le temps tu vas où je m'en vais
avec ceux ayant montré qu' il faut
qu'une situation et une ou plusieurs de
poser devant les cas depuis on a baissé
de 6,4 caractéristiques là pour que ton
cerveau détecte une menace produisent
une réponse de stress faut que la
situation soit nouvelle faut qu'elle
soit imprévus ou imprévisible faut que
tu ailles l'impôt
a sion et sur le sytème l'impression de
tapas le contrôle de sa situation et ça
doit une menaçant pour ton égo en
quelqu'un qui remet en question la
capacité de faire ta job devant dumont
le petit fils inc et l on sait seule
réponse le stress est toujours ce cadre
le toujours les cas le poteau et quand
je te mets au défi de trouver mon arrive
mans avec n'importe quel stresseurs le
choix faire comme gregory charles qui
devait arriver moi qui ne la choque mais
moi je te je m'attèle déconstruire on va
voir ça fait 17 ans que les chercheurs
ont cherché une cinquième c'est erding
est capable d'aller le chercher avec ça
fait que c'est pour ça qu'on stress
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de nouveautés et
prévisibilité pout pout c'est beau mais
pas il si ton cerveau il est capable de
produire une réponse de stress devant
des caractéristiques comme ça tu te
rends compte à quel point tu du pouvoir
sur ton stress relatif si tu changes ta
façon de voir les choses
si tu changes ce qui est imprévisible
petit habitués à cette imprévisibilité
leur gaieté rotary de capoter avec la
nouveauté souvent envoyé le message
attention books permanence peau il va
arrêter de produire des donc on a
beaucoup plus de contrôle qu'on pense
lui plus difficile à faire qu'à dire
dans ce sens qu'il s'y mettant mon ami
capote taguée avec quelqu'un mais je
suis pire on est devant la même
situation
moi je n'ai pas de pot ale capote l'usr
et décapoté ça va pas nécessairement la
fois moins qu'un pas que je te le dis de
suite la dernière affaire à dire à
quelqu'un ce serait si c'est calme toi
là c'est toujours comme ça c'est ça qui
va expliquer les deux différences et
pour moi je dis toujours le stress est
quelque chose d'extrêmement
personnellement quand quelqu'un parle de
mon stress comprends pas pourquoi une
banque parce que c'est donc c'est la
première chose à comprendre mais ça nous
ramène aux préconceptions si dimanche 31
à 10 montus seniors ces menaces up si
c'est sûr et certain ton cerveau tu va
l'amener à détecter de menaces boom qui
va faire sa job il va produire des
hormones de stress de te demander
pourquoi tu es tout jamais en des passes
ne s'y est pas donné de chance de pas
détecter des menaces fait je ne dis pas
qu'on peut tout régler notre stress jeu
sans changer notre façon de penser je
peux en train de réécrire le secret ce
pas ce bon bull nom n'est plus de
pouvoir mais c'est sûr y'a quand même on
est quand même un certain pouvoir
magique et autres les gens qui des gens
qui avaient paul un background de béton
du sport comme moi j'en ai fait ou est
ce que l'espèce de de petite boule dans
le ventre tu la connais tu l'apprivoiser
tu as appris à la calme et à la faire
passer de façon secondaire puis à savoir
que une fin mais moi j'ai côtoyé des
gens qui quand arrivait mettons une
charge de travail grande outil un espèce
de challandes a su remonter qui devenait
pétrifié parce que là le stress arrive
et puis je suis tout avec un coach pour
écoute peut maximiser cette réponse mais
les jeunes il personne n'a jamais dit
c'est pas des farces on s'en rend compte
quand on leur parle sont comme tutu sur
you really good way ya jamais personne
puisse où vais-je parle aux profs de
cégep et des secondes jusqu'à vous
parlez à vos jeunes qu'est ce que vous
leur dites si vous avez la clé dans la
porte de stresser tout le monde je te
ramener quelque chose un autre affaire
de roche que ous avons 2015
on organise le gros congrès mondial sur
le stress ici à montréal chercheurs de
partout dans le monde les allemands
débarquent avec le résultat le plus
fellahi j'ai entendu sur le stress
humain est à ce jour sur la résonance de
stress et de savoir expliqué plein de
choses parce que si je te prend pour
thème dans mon labo puis je te stresse
puis je mesure les hormones de stress
augmente et c'est tout à fait normal
c'est que c'est automatique qui se
mettront à ce que c'est
après tout mesure puis tout va voir dans
le sens où je veux le voir dans la
salive ça va encore aller plus vite mais
je veux répondre à ta question tantôt 4
soit me demander si des différences
graphiques jeudi dans gta même à mon
labo jeta strech mazoutés hormones de
stress et vont augmenter maintenant si
je t'amène à mon la bouche de stress
parce que j'amène dominé puis toi la
dominique le tessin je vois pas titré
site soit juste observer ton collègue
est stressé ce temps avec non c'est
juste le regarder je mesure les hormones
de stress baptise hormones de stress
monte en même temps que celle de ph vous
à les raisonner en semble manquer et on
observe que plus il ya eu lieu en deux
personnes mère fille cheveux blonds et
ses plus vous allez résonner chez eux
c'était déjà arrivé
tu es super zen une journée de bonne
humeur arrive dans un meeting notre
essor de l'opt et comme un lion que on
va résonner donc tout ça en plus tôt non
seulement son interprétation de la
situation puis ok comma ça fonctionne je
suis contrôle etc
mais il y aussi dans quelles conditions
cela te retrouver cette journée là et ça
ça va expliquer que des fois tu sois
déloyaux j'étais capable négocier sa
semaine passée le soudainement cette
semaine je suis capable de négocier des
peut-être en train de bouillonner
quelqu'un auto qui fait juste augmenter
ce que j'appelle tombe bidon de stress
le ça commence à être pas mal plein plus
avancés voire décès c'est fou ce puits
on dirait que de le dire c'est comme si
c'est quelque chose qu'on a entendues
dans d'ivoire ésotérique depuis leur
tactique on raisonne convenait branche
mais comment qu'on m'explique
scientifiquement ce aboyer coutelas les
allemands sont pris pour l'expliquer on
obtient les résultats que l'aimer
moi c'est arrivé mais
et oui mais après pas encore mais ça a
expliqué un résultat que j'avais eue en
2001 dont je savais pas quoi faire
en 2009 la première fois j'avais montré
les effets de débordement du stress
parental sur les enfants j'avais montré
que plus papa et maman est stressé plus
son propre enfin produit des hormones
parce que c'est le parent qui liait le
mammouth à ce moment là mais je me
disais voyons comment ça peut se passer
d'un style doute avait fait cette étude
le études cliniques avec un échantillon
antigènes 500 petits jeunes qui en était
arrivé à cette conclusion là ne sachant
pas comment l'expliquer non donc moi ce
que j'avais fait j'avais mesuré sur
bande et stretch et 500 aux juges
avaient rappelé leur mère en fait leurs
emplettes en passant message aux jeunes
hommes qui m'écoutent on ait aucune
donnée soit on en a pas fac sais pas je
vous dirai pas toujours la faute de la
main c'est juste que quand on appelle la
maison le papa est beau pour la mob ils
veulent jamais répondre aux questions
qu'on n'a pas de données chez les pains
fait que l'on ne parlons maintenant que
ce fût le cas nous pourrons donner le
téléphone monsieur mes potes vous voulez
savoir si le message est fait pour mes
étudiants parce que moi je vais partir
du lot on a montré on a mesuré la
dépression qui laisse très chez maman
puis plus maman était stressé plus son
propre enfant produit des hormones de
stress
aujourd'hui on vous dit baky c'est un
phénomène de résonance qui se fait dans
la maison mais plus loin encore
ils sont allés t la petite école
primaire toujours les mêmes élèves dans
la même classe pour seconde à ça ça se
mélange qui ont mesuré le niveau de
stress du professeur puis les hormones
de stress des élèves de sa classe sa
querelle
on n'est plus dans l'ésotérisme et on
est vraiment dans quelque chose de temps
dans quelque chose insiste m ça fait du
sens
pourquoi parce que en quarts le maroussi
toujours survie de l'espèce
c'est dans une meute mais anna qui
détecte de menaces il faut qu'il passe
le message commencera pas dit bonjour
l'auteur décrit l'ensemble de mes
courriels faut que ça se fasse
exact très très rapidement pilote ça va
bouger mon sens vous oui c'est fascinant
je l'attends pas négliger fait moins
mais je fais de la musique dans la vie
puis ce sont des spectacles avec des
bennes tpiy dès fois suffit qu'ils
mettront qui donne un show piana indart
gagne qui est moins sûr de ces affaires
qui est plus stressé ce jour n'est là
pour une raison x y est resté ça a
effectivement pille on en
ça sent vraiment comme contagieux les
centres visités finalement ça finit que
on est toutes un peu nerveux piquer sa
tente vraiment performance accès
cfoot et puis je pensais justement aussi
une autre anecdote personnelle est cerné
coûtèrent les conférences et puis
justement quand expliquer ce phénomène
le mettons que que les parents varie
vers la maison stressé de son travail
puis inconsciemment votre décharge un
petit peu son stress sur les enfants
pensent avoir un effet il faut être plus
prompts à thé a élevé le ton petit tu
justement pendant des années avec mon ex
copine officielle des spectacles tapis
dans des situations vraiment stressante
qui est ce qu'on a pensé à tout
longtemps voire quatre ans qu'on est ce
qu'on oublie quelque chose comme être
tort est ce que d'ananas le finalement
la remorque sans cela on était toujours
ultra stressée
pis on s'y connaît toujours pas les
pieds mais noël
aujourd'hui on a du recul qui les ont
ils pu rassembler on est on est des bons
amis pour ceux qui ont des crimes que on
était tombé stressé puis on se chicanait
dont mais tout le temps pour des
niaiseries dans le fond monte pas
capable ni moi n'y elle de gérer le
stress est là je vais vous dire ce qui
s'est passé en 10 et 20 jours après le
début du premier confie demain donc je
te dire entre le 20 et le 30 mars 2020
tout le monde a sauté une coche moi
j'aimerais billet de blog moi j'ai sauté
une coche je pas immunisé contre le
stress moi mon cerveau aussi des textes
de maintenance à chaque poule g soutine
coche après mon fils de 19 ans parce
qu'ils me battais au scrabble la chine à
210 heures il y eu ces quinze jours
après le premier jugement
pourquoi j'ai aussi sous le nom qui nous
unit aux normes que je suis simple
aspect voyons dont tu étais antenne du
relais après le petit jérôme cizek
échapper son art de la table de cuisine
qu'à petit quand ils doivent renvoyer au
pit est pas capable de continuer voyons
donc complet pourquoi là on avait de la
colère spontanée en anglais spontanée
singer
c'est un signe ça tu peux face au ch et
un vote c'est sûr et certain et c'est un
signe qu'on est en train de s'habituer
au stress chronique je te donne un
exemple qu'on va le faire chez l'ours
brun pis tu le stress à tous les jours
ces hormones de stress et vont diminuer
avec le tape donc son système va
s'habituer
c'est stressant on va s'habituer à un
pré payés donc l'euro devient habitués
engouement à se centrer sur la chronique
mais il devient hyper réactif à toute
autre forme de nouveaux stresseurs et
donc le doute on est en pandémie depuis
vingt jours c'est long leçon au stress
on commence tranquillement sa nuque mais
on va devenir pas réactif à n'importe
quoi que d'habitude dorée du ben voyons
donc je vous dis vous en avez fait plus
qu'une et vous allez continuer d'en
faire tant et aussi longtemps que cette
pandémie love arrive et c'est parti de
comment le système fonctionne et dont
mais moi ce que j'aime avec ça c'est que
quand j'ai quelqu'un qui me sont une
coche devant moi ce soit au volant etc
j'ai plus de compassion qui avait que je
me dis il doit avoir pas mal plus mal au
ventre de stress que moi on est correct
et en équipe c'est la pandémie justement
les quatre je me demandais bien ce
facteur de stress ou source de stress
l'imprévisibilité la nouveauté les goûts
je sais pas ça ne guérit le quatrième
c'était personnalités menacées bien
jeter dès qu'un acronyme j'ai un
acronyme pour vieux pain acronyme pour
jonathan demme pour moi vous êtes encore
dit ce premier jalon acronyme pour
jeunes c'est spinto stress donc s pour
sens du contrôle faire payer pour
personnalités monastique et légaux la
prévisibilité pineau voter puis tu te
demander à ce que les groupes eux une
menace et ben oui en milieu de travail
le site sur elle même la copie d'un job
l'on va voir que tu vois mal pareil
teixeira dans les 400 toujours eu mais
si on voit quel point justement ça
s'applique tellement parfaitement au
contexte de la coved le titre est
imprévisible et on n'est jamais fixé ccc
ccc y est c'est fait sur mesure pour
nous stresser le voir le way exactement
pis je le dis tout le temps
puis je rencontrais réseau terry que
c'est ce qui fait que les stress
pourtant écoute depuis le 14 mars 2020
on est tous un stress chronique en
passant on n'a pas le choix
chaque matin qu'on se réveille le
cerveau détecte une menace sur sa job
est encore le la pandémie bhupathi ok
moi je dis toujours remettra en janvier
2008 avait quoi trop stressant par
semaine le ton on active du kanak table
en petit active est détecté une menace
faisait une présence de stress à ce
qu'elle met les trois jours plus tard
d'une chicane avec ton coeur réponse de
stress à ce calme est pas parce que je
puisse penser à une autre mais le depuis
14 mois
systématiquement à tous les jours sa
roseraie bout et c'est ça qui explique
les espèces de petits nuages noirs qu'on
au dessus de la tête parce que le
cerveau il détecte des menaces s'ils
détectent des menaces et à force de
remonter à ton cerveau ce que ça va
faire ses hormones là ça va créer ce
qu'on appelle un billet attentionnel
vers la menace bien pays est ton cerveau
aussi biaisés vers la menace est comme
si ton cerveau il se levait matin des
coudes au terran d'où ce que s'est passé
depuis deux mois tabarouette il ya des
menaces à chaque jour puis moi étant
donné que ma job c'est assurer sa survie
je m'arrange et je les ai tous de
trouver fac non seulement est votre
réagir aux menaces mais ils vont aller
chercher eliott souhaite mettre à
détecter des menaces l'otan voyez moi va
l'exemple que je donne toujours juste un
oui j'ai eu il y avait un coût psychique
année et un moment de l'église à sa
blonde et courtois peu importe ce que je
te dis tout en train de sortir le
négatif et j'ai fait de lier
attentionnel vers la menace dont et ça
c'est ça qui explique le petit nuage
noir qu'ont au dessus de la taille qu'on
est comme moi y ont même s'il fallait
une carte de grille d'arbre ou non nous
dit petit oiseau est pas d'oiseau moi
lol parce que ton cerveau est toujours
en détection de menaces
voici la partie ésotérique de ce que
j'en dis mais c'est vraiment vrai
s'il ya un moment dans l'histoire de
l'humanité ou si le temps d'être fait
avec tout le monde
on sait maintenant parce que toute forme
de gentillesse enlève l'impression
cerveau qui est menaces parce qu'il dit
c'est un mammouth dit vrai beau sourire
et c'est ce qui va arrêter les hormones
de stress donc maintenant plus que
jamais faut vraiment être capable de
sortir de dessous puis de s'empêcher de
jeu par là des pharmaciens qui avait
beaucoup de clients qui étaient peu
paniqué pour leurs médicaments tout ce
qu'ils disent est écoutée on a de la
misère sur leurs limites ils puisaient
quand dîner par exemple avec vos amis
dont sur l'heure du midi
arrêtez de parler de kobe depuis du
stress plus loin parce que ce faisant
vous faites juste n'aurait votre cerveau
de cette détection de menaces encore
encore y en a et ce qui arrive c'est
quand l'un d'eux finit plus capable de
gérer parce que t'es jamais de passer
ton heure de dîner à aider ton cerveau a
continué sa job donc le stress peut être
positif parce que quand tu es vraiment
besoin intime et on t'aime et on l'on
fait un podcast est un petit peu stressé
mais je te plus allumés mais oui plus
concentrés plus dans le moment mais
quand ça devient
on a tous les jours plusieurs fois par
jour s'il aime ça devient un stress
chronique plus et pragmatique je donnais
tokyo pour savoir quand est-ce qu'ils
commencent à jouer dans ton cerveau
j'ai étudié ça pendant les temps là tu
peux rien apprendre ça tu peux rien
apprendriez mémoriser si t'as pas
d'abord et avant tout une affaire ce
qu'on appelle l'attention sélective
l'attention sélective c'est la capacité
que tout ce que ton cerveau à
discriminer en ski et pertinents et ce
qui est non pertinent qui va mettre en
mai montrent seulement ce qu'ils
considèrent pertinents je te les disques
il plus pertinent au monde pour un
cerveau si ce qui est menaces à sa
carrière de managing c'est ça maintenant
car nos pôles dont vous voulez vous
rappeler de ce que j'ai dit ok les deux
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
de discriminante ce qui est pertinent à
risque et non pertinente si vous aviez
pris des notes ne se serait pas écrit un
même affaire sur vos papiers parce que
toi tu écris ce que tu considères petit
nom toi tu écris ce que tu considères
pertinents si je fais un examen demain
le nom des deux kidal trouble en c'est
moi qui décide qui est pertinent tiers
chaque fois je fais mon examen
l'université vous donne un cours à
l'université j'ai tout à des étudiants
qui viennent me voir qui dit madame je
comprends projets étudiés étude les
grolles j'ai eu 60% pourquoi mais c'est
simple parce qu'au moment de prendre les
notes le loch pendant qu'on se parle n'a
pas été capable de discriminer en ce qui
était pertinent ce qui était non
pertinents il a passé la semaine à
étudier ce qui était annoncé
j'ai mangé de spaghetti en soirée et
donc je vais te donner le feeling des
auditeurs comprendre quand est en stress
chronique le ca commence à jouer dans
tête
voici quand je parle à quelqu'un qui est
un stress chronique expliquez moi il
vaut toujours face au jeu c'est pas
important pour un portage c'est pour
guerre pile de gauche ruch sont
incapables de discriminer ce qui est
pertinent de ski et non pertinents quand
tu es rendu l'eau ça veut dire que là ça
commence à lui tenté hier en une marche
et il ya eu des mauges et j'ai fait j'ai
perdu des cheveux en fait
puis tout le monde que jacky j'en parle
et puis les médecins que j'allais voir
m'ont dit c'est le stress fait qu est ce
que au delà d'avoir des symptômes
psychologiques est ce que réellement sa
porte des impacts sur
le corps et les cheveux c'est pas sur un
mois le ska légende il est un peu
l'équivalent quand le médecin c'est
parce que tous puissent vivre un peu
moins mais il dans certains cas très
très très très rare on peut le voir mais
c'est pas un effet qu'on va voir chez
tout le monde ok je pense que background
génétique à ça mais si sûr que ça des
effets physiques des effets physiques à
court terme puis des effets physiques à
long terme il ya deux il ya toujours
deux effets avec les hormones de stress
souviens toi ton cerveau détecte de
menaces produit des hormones de stress
79 et physique
ensuite ces hormones de stress le
remonte à ton cerveau ce sera des effets
mentaux ok allons voir les effets
physiques et en a plein les effets aigus
tous les must en dublin parce que le tpr
est au combat est ton carabeau vetex
terrain et je vous donne l indice qui ne
trompe jamais si vous investissez ce
vous allez commencer à avoir mal au
ventre ce type xo chez les enfants aussi
maman papa j'ai mal au ventre et
pourquoi on a mal au ventre quand on est
stressé parce que la digestion vont
ralentir et dans certains grincent et c
est pourquoi parce que ça prend beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie pour digérer c'est
très très énergivores et c'est comme si
le cerveau du xbl
ce pôle tête jerry la 70e à mouthe la
fac toute l'énergie que tu aurais pris
pour jerry cheval apprend qu'ils jouent
à l'envoyer dans tes mu pour te donner
la force surhumaine n'ont pas besoin de
te tombent amoureux et si ce qui va
faire que la digestion va ralentir et
dans une déco celles ci pourront l'issue
de pepto bismol depuis deux semaines et
ça serait le fun qu'on arrête de se
faire accroire que c'est à cause du
restaurant indien où on est allé manger
osmose pas vraiment ce piano plaît mais
continue continue pas digéré continu
continu continu continu glucocorticoïdes
il ya plus qu aux latins ça va jouer sur
le but cause les suit le diabète et de
maladies cardiovasculaires ou une autre
q cela dans nos réseaux sociaux toutes
ces effets le combo mort à long terme
quand les hormones de stress monte au
cerveau le serment à chaque jour là boum
boum boum boum ce qui va arriver c'est
qu'à force de remonter son cerveau jours
après joe ou plusieurs fois par jour ces
hormones de stress le bon tranquillement
mais sûrement commencer à modifier la
façon dont ils vont interpréter la
prochaine situation de telle sorte que
tranquillement pas vite le vert commence
est à moitié vide plutôt qu'à moitié
plein c'est comme ça que des bébés temps
comme la dépression l'anxiété
l'épuisement professionnel
vont se développer puis pour nous un
stress j'ai trois maladies l'os c'est
pas près la même affaire par rapport au
stress de si le chemin j'appelle ça des
tunnels noirs tu rentres dans un tunnel
dont plein falloir un bon bout mines
soit évident à éventuellement ressortir
là mais c'est l'étude s'est échappé sur
les tunnels noirs du stress puis juste
au début complètement puis avec ce que
tu es un deuil qui a eu l'idée de ton
corps qui produit de l'énergie pour
lutter contre un danger potentiel si
cette énergie là et pas utilisé
j'imagine que ça peut juste qu rue g
dans ton énergie puis sur un stress à
long terme de donner l'impression de
toujours être fatigué de toujours et
dedans parce que ton corps produits
d'énergie quand t'as pas besoin
d'utiliser dans le fond si le fun ii
peuvent exactement le super bien résumé
je le dis toujours on est écoeuré de ce
faire dit il faut boucher fin du
suspense pour ce que je te dis c'est pas
ça je m'en fous du parquet
mais la fin je te dis perdre et
l'énergie mobilisée
parce que si tu perds pôle énergie cta
mobilisés à cause du stress baissé d'un
ton cerveau qui va les jouer puis après
c'est exactement ce que tu dis seulement
deux côtés fatigué que c'était un
accident
puis je le dis d'un temps du mammouth le
djia perdait l'énergie mobilisée petit
tuer la bête où il porta kovy scène
d'intro grosse tasse idiot de couru dans
une auto puisque touchant plaît elle
feeling tout valhalla c'est de l'énergie
mobilisée en finlande a qu'un petit fils
unique montanes battu dans son honneur
il faut que tu bouges il se poursuit
jeudi perdre et l'énergie mobiliser les
gens fric parce que ce menu et je leur
dis toujours pas besoin d'aller aux jo
imminents et demie perd de l'énergie
mobilisée le calme notre fait que si tu
veux je m'en fous et je dis ce jour
toujours aux jambes puis contente de
dire aux jeunes
le problème avec les adultes
actuellement deux choses ifric avec le
stress de leurs enfants et pourtant leur
enfant est de loin meilleure que les
parents pour négocier un stress pourquoi
parce que l'enfant fait quelque chose
que l'adulte ne fait plus depuis qui est
adulte et suivent leurs intuitions le
cerveau c'est ce dont il a besoin pour
négocier est raymond ducès l'on n'a
survécu aux mammouths quand même
donc on a tout à l'intérieur de nous
mais le problème que je vois que
l'egypte en parlais tantôt c'est que la
majorité des gens cherchent à
l'extérieur 2 dé façon de négocier leur
stress quand dans le fond ils ont tout à
l'intérieur faction prête à les payer
2500 pièces un week-end de workshop sur
le stress avec une technique
abracadabrante 2 tab électrique au
beurre de pinottes dessus pourquoi ça
marche
la fête semaine d'après vous les faire
un autre 2000 ça marchera pas pub on
finira position foetale en disant il
rien qui marche quand il y avait tout à
l'intérieur d'eux pour négocier le
stresse y avait pas de gourou et 2500
pièces le week end talent temps des
mammouths et pourtant on a survécu à
bien pire qu'une pandémie
donc comme je dis toujours suivez votre
édition tu parlais de la musique pour
tous à diminuer le stress en passe le
sport donc et je dis t'as pas besoin de
faire 15 minutes utilisent peu importe
ce que tu veux bon moi j'ai toujours dit
je vois promener mon chien si je me plus
stressés plus je marche peut être fait
du jogging je suis très stressée pour
celle d'hier à paris à rome et l'autre
façon que j'ai fait et avec mes enfants
tellement souvent dense et puis je dis
toujours que pensez vous que faisaient
les chasseurs de mammouths le soir venu
autour du feu il dansait mais que
faisait-il entassant il perdait
l'énergie mobilisée lors de la chasse je
dis toujours aux gens puis avant de me
dire ça marche paulo asseyez les fêtes
vous le playlist le des cinq meilleurs
tourner dance ou rock ou ce que vous
voudrez jamais créés et quand vous êtes
stressé mais témoin sur surchauffe au
plancher ou luz et avant de me dire ça
marche pour essayer les gens pensent que
c'est moi qui va avec la solution si la
nature nous avait pas donné ce qu'on a
besoin ça fonctionnerait pas la deuxième
chose je vais vous dire je ne sais pas
pourquoi je pense que le cerveau sur un
grand curieux ça existe pas une méthode
universelle pour négocier le stressait
existera jamais fax qui marche pour toi
ça marche pas pour toi que c'est bien
correct it quoi ce qui marche pour toi
aujourd'hui le match à pau demain c'est
progrès un fake
aujourd'hui sa tente de faire surfer les
deux mains se pose pas de question ton
cerveau va t'amener l'eau tu dois aller
dans le goût de faire un cri primal fait
un crime en soi sorti ton énergie par un
pas important mais c'est pas moi demain
matin qui va faire la thérapie par le
club
c'est pour ça marche pas une technique
chez tout le monde ouvrez votre esprit
suivez votre cerveau il va vous avez le
goût de verre
c'est vraiment fascinant de d'imaginer
que l'être humain
en vieillissant déconstruit des choses
qui sont intuitives au final pourquoi
est ce qu'un enfant mais il faut jouer
dehors pileux il bouche d'or puis même
lui il sait pas pourquoi le souvent de
parents veulent l'arrêter complètement
raide on est alors alors que c'est une
façon d'éliminer l'énergie comment tu
l'appeler d'énergie organisent
mobilisent et puis pour faire un lien
puis corrigez moi si je me trompe mais
en direct ça c'est fascinant c'est
incroyable pour reparler delà du cercle
vicieux tout à leur site est paralysé
dans une situation de stress
puis que là tu mobilisé l'énergie mais
que tu l'utilisent pas ben là ça fait
juste continuer la spirale encore
exactement
et donc il faut qu'à perdre leur donne
un exemple je suis pas stressé et coûte
combien de fois j'ai chanté quand tu
chantes la fameuse respiration baden
baden petit cours de bédanne csu panier
du groupe a de la phase de fans c'est le
quand tu rentres dollars dans ton corps
pour ta bd une sorte en même temps
apparaît comme une belle aux tweets pour
picasa labedan sarlat bednarek dati
pourquoi parce qu'en toute ta cage
thoracique est un must qu'on appelle le
diaphragme plus tu fais une grosse
bedaine plus à ces temps puis un certain
niveau d'extension que boom date active
la réponse parasympathique vagal
quelques qu'il arrête mais une façon
enfin la bédaine dans s'en rendent
compte qu'ils chantent et cartouches a
fait de la respiration diaphragmatique
ace a diminué hormones de stress de
veille pour cette aucune technique à
2500 pièces le week-end qui est capable
de descendre une hormone de stress doit
pour ça que me répondre
fake et le nombre de fois j'ai chanté
dans mon auto hoje pris le tartare le
pull et quoi c'est juste parce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne et la nature
nous a donné tout ce dont on avait
besoin
mais tant que je fais l'avocat du diable
je lui dis une personne maintenant j'ai
l'examen des moyens j'ai petit je peux
tu dis je suis vraiment stressé c'est
pas chanter qui va me faire ses études
ils vont pas que les journaux lorsque je
veux dire c'est qu'ils l'ont fait se
rend plus c'est à dire que havas parce
que nous autres les examens si on
appelle ça des stresseurs
environnementaux mon utilise comme
stressant
si on veut pas les stresser en
laboratoire et il y avait une variable
qu'on rentrait qu'on appelle en anglais
le niveau master
c'est à dire que le stresse rc l'examen
toi mais si en plus son niveau de
maîtrise la matière est très très faible
le thé corrélation assez certain
strasser qu'on peut quelqu'un qui est
facilement identifiable régler à la
source le non sens qui est subsidiaire à
montpon pour mon examen étudie puis
thomas 3 6 6 3 pas sur moi mais tant qu
est un niveau de maîtrise bien beau
parce que le pot étudiés moi je pense
que de trouver des navin faut faire
quand même un effet positif statique ça
va être moins bon sur ce volume est en
repos soixante dix pour c'est non plus
j'aurai public amateur va plus rentrer
que si tu es complètement c'est
d'entendre puis comment programmer
comment convaincre mon cerveau qu'une
chose parce que c'est un tout c'est la
distinction entre je me suis dit tant
exact mais tu es une menace absolue
mettons un mammouth puis de menaces
relative relative
comment convaincre que la menace
relative est en fait pour vraiment
maintenant en transmettant moment mon
téléphone timon physiquement cet objet
si je lis proche de moi où je le suis je
trop exposé ça me cause du stress métier
pas une menace
ma santé physique et le ménage on
négocie et se déconstruit répondra
question toi-même selon les quatre
caractéristiques
est-ce que c'est nouveau le ballon mais
ton posé est prévu ou imprévisible oui
oui ça parce que recevoir un message de
quelqu'un qui s'attend pas à n'importe
quelle heure
un appel numéro masqué il rien de plus
angoissant c'est pas avoir le contrôle
la situation
possiblement probablement est-ce que ça
peut être menaçants pour ta personnalité
est ce qu'on prend ce but avec la raison
de diourbel en tige le jeu va t'amener
un état plus loin le nombre de gens qui
viennent me voir qu'ils disent oh je
suis pas stressé mais les gens ils sont
stressés mais ils savent même pas
pourquoi si tu sais pas où le mammouth
servette a séduit duntrade fax et
lorsqu'on est en train de faire depuis
mois ensemble on appelle surtout des
mots pour rien dit à des constructions
et de la reconstruction de ce triste et
utilise une carte en tout et donc des
mots pour une non merci
c'est la première fois que j'entendais
quelques utiliser le monde et
construction du monde répond pour une
fois les gens tout ce bain compliqué
quand on leur dit ça comme ça mais c'est
juste que ça veut dire
donc à chaque fois d'une situation
quitté stress qui l'a déconstruit ans
son spin mathon hockey comme on vient de
faire briller et lotus et que cette
situation le stress parce que ces
imprévus tapas le contrôle si menaçants
pour ton et goûteux déjà la moitié de la
job de films x 4 se trouve un petit peu
maintenant
une fois que tu as déconstruite on
stresse ce voleur reconstruit puis tu
vas voir pourquoi je veux faire faire ça
le mot inverse de stress ce n'est pas la
relaxation c'est pas parce que tu vois
dans un sport ce week-end que la
pandémie est parti le temps pour lui
lundi matin la survenue en tant que le
mot inverse de stress et la résilience
et la résilience la capacité d'avoir un
plan b c d tu dois trouver un plan
jusqu'à ce que tu as l'impression que le
plan que tout fonctionnerait pas dicté
allait le mettre en action le
fonctionnerait temple la tonte idiots
qui socialisent c'est stressant parce
que j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir le
contrôle sur la situation soit
reconstruite soit dire ok qu'est ce que
je peux faire pour avoir l'impression
d'avoir plus de contrôle l'autre cherche
un plan b un futur que deux fois ci
dessous du ca marche au dessus de nous
vous recherchez un plan qu'ils soient
chercher un pelage contacts a eu
l'impression que ça fonctionnerait quand
ça s'est fait par acte voici
l'information importante
95% des gens ne mettront jamais en
action le plan b c'est pas grave on a
montré que la prochaine fois que la
situation stressante en voir
mène à la conscience dont plan b sa
dette au cerveau que le contrôle c'est
tout ce qui est besoin pour arrêter de
produire des hormones de stress pour hbo
et comme je dis toujours aller plus
jamais devant istres et soeurs c'est un
plan b c'est l'équivalent d'aller
chasser mahmoud pas de lens là et ça
c'est très très fort ça fonctionne
admirablement bien
les gens aiment pas beaucoup
déconstruire construisent une idée aussi
plate etc
mais ça fonctionne vraiment j'ai
l'impression que vraiment une bonne
partie des gens stressés ou anxieux
c'est qui premièrement à ce que c'est
quoi ces distinctions stress et
l'anxiété de l'entité c'est quand ça
devient chronique ou non ça c'est
toujours la question qu'on pose la
différence en stress et anxiété
j'adore les ados tutu pourquoi parce
qu'un ado ça pas encore assez de lobe
frontal pour inhiber des comportements
inappropriés fac quand tu vas avoir
l'heure juste par là un hindou de
raconte l'histoire vraie vie tout en 2d
dans une école secondaire puis donne une
conférence sur l'anxiété de performance
aux jeunes l'attitude des bleus même si
madame différents centres et 5,6 alors
je lui donne une réponse que je
considère intelligent et je poursuis
deux secondes plus tard rêve la main et
madame je vous ai compris à qui je donne
un autre casse notre réponse que je
considère intelligent et je poursuis
quelques secondes plus tard la flamme à
toulon mais je continue à penser que non
et là je la regarde mais un mot
tellement poussé dans mirant corp qui
m'a permis de trouver la meilleure
réponse après 3h à 2h de ma cocotte le
la différence entre le stress et
l'anxiété c'est la localisation du
mammouth dans le stress le mammouth et
directement toi prêtre est attaqué dans
l'anxiété y ait dans ta tête mais pour
ton cerveau que le mammouth soit devant
toi ou dans ta tête c'est la même menace
boom
il va produire les mêmes hormones de
stress il est surtout très applaudi tout
le monde avait compris avant qu'il
devienne trouver là c'est vraiment
vraiment sur les services que ce soit je
dis toujours on pense toujours que les
stress d'une grosse bête poilue qui nous
attaque de l'extérieur c'est faux
croyez-moi le rester chez vous puis
ruminer assez long terme sur tout ce qui
va mal sur la table vous allez vous
produire assez dormi tout seul dans
votre salon loin et c'est ce qu'il faut
comprendre donc l'anxiété c'est quand
ton cerveau pense que tout le temps
menacée qui sacre est constant
les personnalités anxieuse ont une
capacité que vous et moi n'avons pas et
elle voit dans le futur et donc elles
vont toujours ce soir là le mammouth il
aborde la porte
ce potentiel dont s'est jamais que
peut-être que dans dix ans que peut-être
que même s'ils avouent y voit une menace
eu du monde on est une menace big boy
fac pour il produit des hormones de
stress et si ce qui va faire que les
personnalités anxieuse va être un petit
peu plus en réactive au stress peur
qu'on ait soit juste à dire une chose
dans le monde scientifique du stress le
banc psychiatrie le moi je ne parle dans
la science du stress l'anxiété n'est pas
un trouble mental c'est un vestige de la
préhistoire
pourquoi c'est quoi un anxieux un axe
husting super détecteur de man a sonné
dacca qui croyez-vous que les chasseurs
de mammouths remettait le soir venu pour
faire le guet pendant que les fans de
dos je suis leur gueule mettait des
actions qu'ils aillent votre compte
hormis ceux qui t'ont maman et donc
était très très payant dans le temps des
mammouths les anxieux sauf
qu'aujourd'hui un moyen de menaces mais
on a encore ce vestige de gens qui
prennent pas de chance et c'est pour ça
que quand on dit qu'une épidémie
d'anxiété cette anxiété la le plusieurs
formes c'est pas juste pathologique mais
c'est ça je veux faire comprendre aux
gens en termes de stress ya pas de bons
pi de mauvais il ya différentes
personnes qui vont être différents
morceaux du pozo pour assurer la survie
de l'espèce si on était tout pareil
en réaction au stress a réagi cet autre
pareil on aurait jamais sur les consoles
mais j'ai l'impression que une partie de
la population très déjà des gens
stressés ou anxieux camani on n'est même
plus capable de nommer ou de reconnaître
prendra peut-être collins tracy ou
anxieux qui quelles sont les causes
three gm raison camani c'est évidemment
une est ok mais quand on stresse
immédiate et once boule dans le ventre
de réponse est immédiate mais quand
c'est tout le talent de n'être constant
j'ai l'impression que ça devient normal
et difficile de savoir pourquoi tu es
stressé bain
je sais pas je sais plus si mais c'est
pour ça que je dis j'en parle dans le
dernier bouquet j'ai commencé le dernier
livre comme seule la donne et j'écris
cet été une jeune femme six mois c'est
trop long tu me donnes une solution
quand je les lis ton lit ceci est vrai
quand tu achètes la première page sur l'
concluraient à la véraison j'ai ciblé
code flash this past était stressé tempe
ou d'attendre 400 pages du combat mais
je commence en disant que me donner des
solutions des stress hydriques loppsi 2
nous tu te rappelles va me pose que je
te le dis ce que tu décris là ce sont
les effets des hormones de stress sur
ton sort ou non les hormones de stress
sont atteintes au cerveau petit plus
capable penser correctement oublie seul
ne sera pas capable fait qu' il faut que
tu ailles ton corps a arrêté de produire
des hormones de stress pour car être
d'aller dans ton cerveau pour que l'otan
puisse commencer à des bons thèmes tels
que ce qui se passe mais ça je répète ce
que j'ai dit tantôt la meilleure façon
c'est d'utiliser ton campus dans le
livre donne plein plein plein de
solutions des choses aussi bizarroïde
que chanter faire du sport je sais que
ça fait qq c'est quand même ce qui
fonctionne flatter un chien n'importe
quoi de un animal quelconque ça va
diminuer les hormones de stress on sait
pas trop pourquoi mais ça fonctionne
n'importe quoi qui va diminuer les
hormones de stress et après moi je parle
je dis j'ai élevé mes enfants qu'ils ont
eus des stress comme toutes les jeunes
mais quand il était rendu trop loin on
n'était plus dans paroles et on va aller
promener le chien
à l'écouter on va écouter les disques au
complet enfin peu importe
après si on se parlera mettant pour
illustrer ce mode et fois qu'un mettons
oui je travaille toute la journée
plusieurs des mails qui rentrent qui
sortent plus une espèce de
d'accumulation de imagine de stress qui
s'accumulent à un point où est ce que
mon année est saturé je suis plus
capable de prendre des décisions si je
suis capable maintenant je réalise que
lorsque j'étais en train d'écrire
c'est pas la qualité que je ferais mais
ton citait si j'avais un esprit clair
puis là je vois faire du sport puis
quand je reviens c'est comme un bruit 7
comptait sept couples on dirait vraiment
claque la clarté d'esprit-- revient
complètement neutre sur pitié de toi
c'est le sport un autre après été
écoutés
seydou complet l'autre ça pourrait était
d'écouter le rire ça fait diminuer les
hormones de stress moins que j'écoute
les fermes sur youtube coach quoi ça que
moi je me fais de la mire de souche
korek après ouais mais le problème c'est
qu'on perçus sont perçus sont permis
surtout jamais efficace qui personnalise
arrive à un espèce de ce genre de samui
homme entend l'est avant le type d
arrière arrière grand parent le était
sur une terre mon frère d'un boeuf en
train de semer
ouais ça c'est dur de se faire menacer
les coûts par un boeuf des d'accord de
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
l'humain actuellement n'a jamais autant
utiliser son cerveau jamais on est en
train d'être ce d'adapter une au niveau
de saturation et ton grand-père lui là
il travaillait du corps toute la journée
y lisait le journal une fois par mois
quand il les recevait pid article et
donc quand il était très fatigué
physiquement est tombé littéralement
mais en servons se pose même sas major
on continue on continue les j'ai même
des collègues et 10 pour qu'on soit
vraiment santé pour chaque heure
travaillée de la taille de faudrait
faire une heure travaillée du coffre et
d'art
mais oui mais on exactement raison mais
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ça pareil
et donc faut pas hésiter a juste lâché 8
face au trop peu efficace on savait tous
autant que moi c'est pas parce que c'est
pas le nom d'assas calcule pas au nombre
d'arh une performance à ce calcul à
l'appel en fait que met-on justement
maïs et ça exactement puis je voyais
jouer une publication dernièrement
c'était au niveau du thil et le concept
de devolder le tiff calmes et ont du
travail la maison pitch plus d'or que
puis les l'idée de d'être payés selon
les heures de travail versus la tâche
accomplie est vraiment idiote en fait
qu'un qu'on y pense comme ce à moins que
ce soit un job de brancher des disques
est alors le team et quand ce travail de
chez vous la tâche accomplie vaut
beaucoup plus que les autres travaillent
est passé en 20 sec tu devrais être
récompensés maintenant moi je pense que
la pandémie va avoir eu un impact mon
dieu qu'on était due sur la nature du
travail le nombre d'attaquants de
travailler sur l'histoire de
l'industrialisation c'est quand les gens
travailler sur des machines qu cling
cling aux flics de dollars calculé mais
quand tu travailles en performance
fonctionne peau prend deux personnes
ayant une hyper efficace qui allume
vitelotte a le moins vite hissé jeudi ça
prendra pas le même temps et donc
j'espère que ce qu'on va avoir vu avec
la pandémie sol on va avec des niveaux
de performance et non pas du temps du
temps travail il
les apports et c'est le stress causé par
la pandémie
j'ai l'air est chose qui vienne couper
là c'est moi qui vient de racheter dont
il est consultant
j'ai l'impression de me corriger si je
me trompe que mettant les jeunes pythie
de nos jours en général on est plus
stressé que jamais peut-être puis kaka
réalité je dois la menace absolue il y
en a pratiquement aucune un sens qu'on
n'ait jamais été aussi siffler dans vie
n'était si les pommes d'amour qui va
rentrer ici des chances qui était qui
est vraiment une menace réelle à ma
santé ma survie mais qu'est ce qui
explique ce qu'on le fait qu'on soit
aussi stressé de nos jours nathan selon
toi ben la pression de la forme à cette
technologie
une situation d menaçante que si votre
cerveau
l'interprète comme étant menaçant parce
qu'il ya plus une menace à la survie
vraiment même la pandémie c'est du
stress relatifs et donc on s'est posé la
question ce coup donc comment ça c'est
que tout le monde capote de toute
l'histoire de l'humanité
l'humain n'a jamais été en sécurité
haute jamais jamais jamais et pourtant
il ya des milieux de travail dans
lesquelles c'est la moitié c'est pour
des troubles liés au stress au travail
etc cnra et je pense que nous sommes
notre pire ennemi
nous nous générons se propre stress est
ce ça vient des médiums jeu peut cracher
ses médiums et c'est vraiment vrai c'est
quoi qui avait pas chez nos arrière
grands parents qui ont maintenant tous
ces médias
je fais l'exercer je le fais dans une de
mes conférences tu le frelon en arrivant
chez vous tantôt le tout à un vote sur
le google puis dans kiwi stress le
regarde les images qui va te montrer
c'est quoi qui va te montrer c'est
toujours quelques expos note non c'est
tout
tempérament sportif on parle toujours du
négatif on parle et je me dis mon dieu
la façon dont on parle de l'humain on
est de comment qu'on a fait pour
survivre jusqu'à ce jour
moyon dont on peut pas être si si petit
si faible que ça ça n'a aucun sens mais
y'a vraiment cette espèce de c'est un
mode des négatifs de nos jours ça
m'énerve c'est toujours un modèle
toujours négatif de touche pour donner
un exemple je te rends concerne que je
te dis comment ça va deux minutes ça va
super bien je vais continuer mon chemin
vous avez vos biens mais maintenant je
te rends compte jusqu'à moi ça vaut
faire mais je vais accorder de
l'attention points et donc des théories
évolutive des troubles mentaux qui dit
que souvent les troubles mentaux existe
comme un message qu'on envoie alors
qu'on a besoin d'amis qu'on a besoin de
cet arrêt était un isolement social etc
ça pourrait de ce genre de choses là
qu'on voit mais je pense aussi que en
changeant notman hince est souvent en
changeant notre façon de voir les choses
et déjà quelqu'un qui m'a dit c'est
quétaine des positif pourtant c'est
quand même assez c est donc je pense
qu'on est tout seul toutes ces menaces
le virtuel qu'on voit tout les domaines
exemple moi je me suis toujours relevé
vent mais enfin pour les mon journal
tranquille avec ses lèvres depuis un
moment donné c'était d'autant que la
petite cédrika provencher venait d'être
enlevée par le l'un d'eux l'a jamais
fait la gamme atteste entraîné mon
journal et c'est écrit allons nous l'a
retrouvée assassinée violi et en lisant
le journal
je sens une réponse de stress lui là je
me dis guesdon kadanga dont le cerveau
est un détecteur de menaces se
pourrait-il que quand je lis où il fait
sa job d'état qu'une menace le jeu
produit des hormones de stress
en lisant ce jugement as tu déjà regardé
les titres de journaux il ya toujours un
mot négatif je te jure et donc je
revenais où la boue puis - la pole
avantages que je sais que je peux
l'étudier régis diamaguène ont enfin
l'étude donc on a pris deux groupes de
personnes un groupe à qui on leur fait
dire des vrais nouvelles qu'on avait
pris d'entrée journal de montréal
négatit toujours des monégasques et un
autre à qui on avait fait lire des
nouvelles notes ça a été tellement dur
de trouver des nouvelles notes dans le
journal de 6 heures au sein même le
cahier santé samedi dans
c'est toujours un mot négatif genre
mélange et du jus de pamplemousse avec
un anticholestérol et mick deux points à
cocktail explosif journal bref on a
trouvé des nouvelles notes a et t2 puis
on a fait lire les deux types de
nouvelles aux gens puis ensuite on les
expose à un stresseurs parce qu'on
voulait avancer le fait de lire des
nouvelles négatives à l'augmenter tard
et activités au stress puis ensuite on
leur fait trois jours plus tard on les
aurait appelés pour leur demander de se
rappeler des nouvelles et on a montré
que particulièrement les femmes on sait
pas pourquoi quand seulement quand elles
lisent les nouvelles négatives elles
vont être beaucoup plus réactive au
stress par la suite ils vont se souvenir
entre 20 et 30 % plus de cette
information est donc un cerveau
peut-être c'était en détection de
menaces nous tiens c'est juste c'est ça
une réponse de stress et un cerveau
c'était en détection de menaces
pose toi la question dans ta journée
combien de monastir est plus juste et
barcelo j'en ai pas de besoin et c'est
pour ça que je dis que tu peux être
certain que quand moelleux mon bidon de
stress et aux trois quarts plein j'ai
mon cher aux québécois c'est sûr et
certain que je dirais pas une nouvelle
c'est sûr il me prend dix romans à l'eau
de rose coups de coutelas et seulement
quand mon bidon de stress est redevenu
normal je remets ta joue dans les
nouvelles parce que sa seule cette
menace la selle lâche pas contrôler la
pandémie chevaux capable mais le losc a
pas ses seuls
on dirait que c'est un peu un challenge
parce que mettons moi je me prends un
exemple moi je le plus possible restez à
l'affût de l'actualité
puis je suis tout à fait au courant de
l'effet que ça me fait tout à fait au
courant quelqu'un je lis quand je vois
ces médias sociaux puis que je vois
passer telle personne est un agresseur
back to back avec avec une tuerie à
québec back to back avec tout un show
leurs trois buts à stresser tremblay m'a
stressé
je pense que c'est le monde entier sait
qu'à chaque jour c'est une nouvelle fois
en dépit mais en même temps - je sais
que je sais que je serai probablement
moins stressés puis plus grande et si
justement comme peu comme mon père
autrefois si j'habitais au laos à côté
d'une dans une rizière
sauf que sauf que il sait comme la
dichotomie entre vouloir être à l'affût
qui restait à de mon époque pour essayer
d'avoir le plus d'impact positif
possible qu'ils décident de faire
avancer plusieurs causes puis de l'autre
côté c'est de me dire peut-être que de
juste ne plus du tout m'impliquer ça
serait une façon de de vivre plus
calmement mettons ma vie le tiff et que
c'est quand même comment jongler c'est
ce que j'ai observé quand je me mets sur
off dijoux jeu toujours à jour le tout
cas quelques moments parlés
mais il ment perdra pas comme le journal
soit mon fils je dois y monte de tubes
sous telle affaire puis foot et ça me
stresse un peu mais je lis polotti le
genre écrit en rouge sur background noir
wever ne veut pas je peux pas jamais et
à jour se sait l'amour enfin mais je
donne un exemple je peux la première à
parler de tous les jours il en dira
chipie trop ils se sont rendus compte
que le journalisme dans des niches ta
radio j si les journalistes vous avez un
problème de santé publique parce que si
c'est vrai ça si je continue et l'europe
d'hier dont un problème de santé
publique auquel vous allez devoir penser
un groupe de journalistes en europe qui
ont réalisé ça aussi qui ont commencé à
créer un vous donner un exemple ce qu'on
appelle le journalisme constructif voici
la règle du journalisme constructif a
ride de jus sera portée du négatif tu
peux te permettre de rapporter du
positif premièrement sans voir
l'aquitaine ce n'est pas vrai que
positif égale qu'étaient nos mesures
arrêtées sur et deuxièmement si tu dois
absolument apporter une nouvelle
négative tu dois apporter un élément de
solution ou quelqu'un qui va proposer
une solution sinon ferme ta gueule et
donc de ce mouvement le de journalistes
constructif et commencé à naître est ici
au québec est un journaliste qui
s'appelle laurent et beau qui cette
année des journaux est négatif et ya
créé un site web
moi quand ça va pas bien dans ma tête
globo gonesse et ce gars là il travaille
fort il essaye de
année à travers le monde des nouvelles
positives mois d'avril puis je te le dis
le camp ça commence à ton ferme elle va
juste voir que je sois et donc tu vas
aller chercher un peu plus de positif
pour empêcher ton cerveau de trop
détecter des menaces tout en me donner
mon autre truc pour quand mon cerveau
détecte trop de menaces
comment kg j mal puis il va le calmer
moi j'appelle ça mon papy thérapie mots
sur mon compte instagram c'est pas
compliqué j'ai juste dit popping 20,80
papineau money c'est juste ça à
quelqu'un gentil monchal je me fais pipi
thérapie c'est tout c'est tout ce que je
veux je sais exactement ce que je
m'envoie chercher mais j'ai calme
jacquet le cerveau en arrêt que l'art
est de détecter des menaces je vois pas
aller les la praille sera rendu à 10h15
le soir quand j'ai eu mon char j'aurais
juste me donner une pause je vois juste
mais dormir
jeannot un autre exemple il ya un acteur
américain qui s'appelle john krasinski
qui joue jim dandy au festi pluie aude
et id au début du premier confinement
justement à travers toutes les négatifs
qui justement les 6/10 le monde ont
besoin d'un peu de lumière latifah qui
il ya partie sur youtube en espèces des
séries d comme de nouvelles fnac majeur
de téléjournal s'appelait some good news
c'était juste des nouvelles positives
texte est juste lui chez eux de théâtre
car chez ça a marché
à côté mais ça supermarché quitter le le
concept va devenir autre chose parce a
été acheté par un d un réseau va faire
quelque chose mais tu des crimes tels
les gens ont besoin de ça on a besoin de
partir je parlais déjà destinés aux
travaux les gens ont besoin d'arrêter de
détecter des menaces à temps complet
quelle qu'elle soit mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait même temps à m'amener mettons
qu'on aime et on constate ce qui a
vraiment sa membrane de santé publique
avec comment que le journalisme est fait
on pourrait dessus et instaurer un quota
de nouvelles positives au téléjournal
arts du canada s'apprête ce quelque
chose qui vend des nouvelle parce qu'ils
oublient point ça se vend parce que ça
s'arrêterait pas fait volontairement
seul on se promène à périgueux tableau
plaisir des petits stand ploemeur et
promène plus tu vois sur un stand le
site écrit meurtre crapuleux
prie ton attention c'est sûr et certain
ton cerveau détecte une menace tout on
attend on cherchait journée puis tu vas
t'asseoir tu veux lire ce qu'on prend il
ya quelque chose d'instinctif c'est pour
assurer la survie de l'espèce mais mais
oui je dis je les ai toujours dit réjean
quétaine ce sont les gens heureux ce que
je veux dire c'est que ce que moi je
vois là on a history en culture cette
espèce de ces [ __ ] et négatifs plus et
c'est bien tout va mal et c'est quand un
oeil qui est trop fleur bleue et du
bozziu justement dit les flammes bleues
14 coupable de je vous souhaite
je vous souhaite de changer ça je vous
le souhaite sincèrement parce que pour
avoir stressé du monde puis d'en avoir
étudié temps dans ma vie c'est une
erreur de façon si vrai que je souhaite
que les jeunes moi je trouve que vous
avez tellement changé de chambre
médicale imm vous avez parlé de
diversité et cetera l'antique et n est
l'anti positif ça pour être quelque
chose le concours et j'y songerai c'est
vrai puits mais en même temps mais dont
moi j'ai fait de mon parcours je fais
jusqu'à maîtrise en littérature
puis mes meilleurs parle créative était
quand je vivais des énergies négatives
car j'avais des émotions négatives sur
une période prolongée
quand tout va bien j'écris pas je trouve
pas que c'est bon ce que je fais le tri
peut-être parce que c'est pas moi je
dirais l'enfant à chaque fois que le
cerveau fait quelque chose
même en dépit du fait qu'on se dit que
c'est pas bon on se dit ben il fait pour
une raison
je vous donne un exemple rue binet un
petit cri ni à quoi ça sert de moi genou
genou je pense que chacun de nous on
aime ce temps en temps se faire une
belle petite chose d'apitoiement sur
fond peu importe que les gens m'ont même
si on essaye de s'arrêter on wulf on
comprend ça même à face que tu dis c'est
que toutes les grandes écrits ont été
écrits dans des moments peut-être que
l'émotion négatif c'est à ça que ça sert
dans
la survie de l'espèce a annoncé aux
autres l'envié et puis comment gérer
piquante et heureux mais tout a job
c'est d'aller rendre les autres heureux
en virevoltant dans un jardin où je sais
pas trop quoi c'était sur la nature
c'est pas à moi de décider mais quand tu
regardes qui s'est faite comme dit tes
ratures tu as raison absolument
peut-être effectivement que c'est une
façon d'avertir la postérité d'une
énergie team et on va donner l'exemple
de germinal de zola qu'on avait parlé
avec patrick senécal peut-être que c'est
pour avertir que la prochaine fois
qu'ils vont avoir d une situation au
travail vraiment exécrable peut-être que
le monde vont réveiller rapidement
puisque ça fait en fait les habitants
tout il dit bien aussi c'est le fait de
vouloir rester à l'affût de l'actualité
sa nuque raide ou un stress mais tim est
on si on s'expose pas à se il est quand
même des injustices mais quand les
choses dans le monde continuent négatifs
qui ont continué à vie puis pour ceux
qui mettront les les militantismes c'est
aussi dur c'est d'être toujours exposés
aux choses les plus âgés pour vouloir
change mais l'effet que ça te fais en
tant que les trucs pas l'impression
d'avoir le contrôle tout le temps le
seul hic ou anxiété j'avais parlé des
jeunes n'était pas ce qu'elle veut c'est
tellement gros ouais la chance de
contrôler
allez vous allez péter offrir si souvent
et donc ma tu peux faire pour avoir pigé
t on va découvrir la france
ok je mendie construire ensemble un
bourdon qui fait que peux tu faire pour
avoir l'impression d'avoir un peu plus
de contre robin je peux commencer dans
mon école ben t'as tout compris comment
s'en étonner qu aux immigrés j'ai pas
moins organisation dans tokyo tu le vois
tu vois dans les unes l'hôte de vente ou
le brun platitude bon jeu juste
augmenter ton m6 a conservé à deux
besoins ne peut pas changer l'humanité
m'intéresse a dû commencer petit souza
ci-dessus relevé l'humanité vous allez
arriver nulle part et dont je pense que
beaucoup de l'éco anxiété qu'on voit
c'est sous ces fascinants si mettons que
je le transpose dans ma situation par
rapport aux véganisme moi je suivais
gagnent
depuis trois ans maintenant puis je suis
beaucoup plus distancé que je l'étais
quand je suis devenu plusieurs raisons
mais notamment le fait que si tu
commences à voir tout le monde autour de
toi comme des meurtriers
t'es pas capable d'aller de l'avant le
type n'a aucun impact au final pas peur
d'être stressé du soldat ses seuls les
apports de sentir le monde peu importe
ce que tu vas faire c'est sûr je parle à
des méthodes et conques siete ou
d'anxiété chez les jeunes est ce que
tendent où je suppose et sur la question
parce que c'est ce que si mesurable
c'est ce qui m'a élevé génération est
plus stressé que celle qui l'a précédée
ou pas nécessairement ben en fait on
parle beaucoup plus de stress qu'on
entend reconnaître serait peut-être un
petit peu plus de nouveautés de ce happy
new year au début de la fuite deux ans
les profs sont nouveaux dans nos centres
d'études du stress humain mon labo plomb
dix soignants de foot une jungle où une
épidémie dac cité dans les écoles depuis
la fin de la fin 70 % de jeunes ont reçu
dans vos écoles quand ils vont arriver
adultes survie d'espèces de raies
qu'avec une de mes étudiantes audréanne
journaux qui voulait faire son dock là
dessus bon en tout cas travailler france
est enfin le on le fait l'étude chez dit
je pense qu'on a trois quatre mille
jeunes dans les écoles primaires puis
dans les écoles secondaires jeudi le la
première affaire qu'on va en faire du
ménage
de quoi on parle moi y'a pleins titres
d'anxiété piano de l'anxiété qui est
normal qu'elle l'ait toac sus d'un état
c'est normal c'est à dire que le domaine
à un examen c'est normal que tu as reçu
avant ton examen tu veux est anxieuse
augmenté ta performance canton examens
vont être finis ton anxiété va diminuer
ok il faut examen où on aime le
protocole au super bonne personnalité
anxieuse tout est un détecteur de
menaces tu prends pas de chance départ
efficace dans la vie ça aussi c'est
normal que la sensibilité à l'anxiété
dont je vous ai parlé tantôt c'est des
gens qui quand le cerveau est stressé
normalement ils capotent devant la
réponse est on a mesuré aussi l'anxiété
de performance est pourquoi l anxiété de
performance parce que ce qu'on sait dans
les écoles du québec ait jamais eu
autant d'examens aykut des examens y en
a depuis qu'on a le classement tout vas
des examens tout le temps il ya eu une
augmentation faramineuse et souviens toi
que je t'ai dit que moi dans mon monde
on utilise les examens comme strasser
environnement tous bonjour bref si vous
en mettez 44 dans une année bien ce qu
on se revoyait britannique améliorer ses
pratiques
ça qu'on a mesuré c'est qu'à pas faire
et on se construit on observe c'est que
vraiment les deux types d'acier tic sont
très très très élevé c'est le très en
dessus donc cette personnalité anxieuse
là ils sont là prince à la maison ouais
enfin qui est personnel et anxieuse t'es
sûr et certain qu'il y aurait des deux
parents qui est anxieux il ya une
passation génétique faible 30% et à 70%
saut d'appel soit par apprentissage
icariens ou apprentissage par modelage
site à un parent qui est un spa
détecteur de manas lundi bon tu seigneur
va pas au parc du seigneur si jamais il
ya quelques temps à l'est mais qu'est ce
que tu as prince avec un ouais tu
apprends que le monde est un endroit
extrêmement dangereuse
j'ai peut-être que c'est un micro
exemple de ce je ne sais pas si ça peut
être situationnelle ce genre de chose le
moi j'ai une peur bleue des chauves
souris puis c'est arrivé je pense que
personne ne remarque qu'ils adorent voir
sourit mettons là mais moi ça me fait
paniquer parce que c'est arrivé qu'on
était au chalet puis il ya une chauve
souris qui est rentré par le foyer
tu as mon père s'il met à crier qu'ils
avaient déjà cacher vos cheveux et puis
la machine jaune pisseux le maintenant
ils sont capables de grandes choses si
je ne suis rien de chaud sourit le
stress le conditionnement par c'est ce
qui explique aussi que beaucoup de gens
veulent pas céder confiné du premier
confinement
j'ai créé un billet de blog là dessus
c'est à la passe et next level
ok tu l'as pas ça s'apprend une shot
donne un exemple je perds je la mets
dans une pièce ça reconnaît son
environnement va reconnaître les
posteurs ici exactement you leur bouquet
et là je le prends puis je le mets dans
une cage puis sur le plancher hiram ans
un moyen choc électrique qui fait mal
aux qui laisse à penser à l'éthique view
qu'est le jeu le ramène ta titre je
laisse tranquille six mois plus tard je
la rends dans un opiacé suis parisienne
je fais juste leur entrée j'ai ouvert la
porte quasiment ils vont geler sur place
donc la passe et a pris en une shot et
pourquoi des gens qui sont traumatisés
le savent ce qui est maintenant le plus
dur c'est de désapprendre là
d apprendre la pensée super long
pourquoi parce qu'il faut que tu dises
après n'en avoir pas et du désastre en
avoir par en réapprenant cat est en
sécurité
mais pour cela il aurait fallu qu'il
soit exposé au chantage est-ce qu'une
pop
est ce qu'une pâle et transmises
génétiquement mettons mettons mon père
est allé au vietnam il revenu
programmatique sur des problèmes
est ce que moi je méritais le train j'ai
écrit ça dans mon deuxième livre qui
s'appelle à chacun son stress le des
effets du stress des parents sur les
enfants je raconte la chercheure la plus
connue 80 sera au shoot
donc les gens qui sont allés dans les
camps de concentration riccioli ou donne
bonne copie d'un mois puis à le montrer
que les gens qui sont à la route choisie
pour sur tout ce désordre d'origine post
traumatique là là là c'est bon on est
quelque part aux états unis à deux pas
d'un congrès pinceau a dit là j'ai
découvert quelque chose de bizarre quoi
aider les enfants de ces gens là qui ne
sont jamais allés à auch 8 mondes
désordre d'origine post traumatique
bardon la clotte a plusieurs
possibilités à ce soit que ça a été
passée génétiquement et on sait que
c'est ça peut arriver aussi ça s'appelle
l'épigénétique je vais te la raconter
dans deux minutes et aussi les
comportements parentaux c'est à dire que
tu as des parents qui ont des
comportements de désir d'origine post
traumatique
l'épigénétique c'est quoi la différence
entre la génétique et d'épis génétique
avant on pensait que la juste jeunes et
tout était génétique tu avais le règne
de la schizophrénie par exemple extase
jeune talent est devenu schizophrénie
sont rendus compte que benneteau est
plein jeunes qui ont le gène de la
schizophrénie et deviennent peu
schizophrène
l'épigénétique c'est l'interaction entre
le jeune et l'environnement est ce que
ça veut dire c'est que tu peux avoir le
jeune de la schizophrénie mais si tu
grandis pas dans un environnement qui
voit l'ouvrir comme un interrupteur on
off
donc si tu grandis dans un environnement
adverse cet environnement lui ouvrait
ton jeune pilote me développer la
schizophrénie mais si tu grandis dans un
environnement qui est potro magasin ou
pas trop stressant soit le ca off et ça
pourrait expliquer justement la
passation qu'on appelle
intergénérationnelle du trou mais
comment ça va se passer d'une
d'une part quatre gardes l'ont montré si
tu traumatisera trois générations après
tu as encore des effets chez les
descendants away trois générations
passent par le sperme du père c'est pas
parce qu'ils étaient élevées par le rock
était traumatisé le temps parce qu'il
sait par des matches comme ça c'est fou
way you lie c'est fascinant par exemple
mais c'est parfaitement bien fait se
trouve point oui oui oui tout et tout et
quand je regarde parce que quand on fait
pour assurer la survie est exact sur
tout le temps au début le traumatisme
d'un prédateur niveau de deux parents
enfin y'a rien qui ait fait porter
carrés tout est fait pour t&d [ __ ] de
la survie culte si on peut comprendre
surtout le temps il ya pas une fois
qu'on a trouvé quelque chose qu'on sait
dire non à chaque fois ti dit ben oui
c'est comme ça que ça va se développer
dans le livre ses pièges aussi y parle
de tikal l'humain découvert où commencer
faire de l'agriculture un lit commencent
à faire des réserves ses pieds pour
qu'ils se projeter plus un peu dans
l'avenir de qu'il aura besoin de temps
plus on le plus de ressources ce qu'on
va faire plus d'enfants
on va prendre une place debout fils à la
croissance comme commencé comme ce tout
lui arrive à une est prévu arrive une
année une sécheresse la rivière fu là on
avait prévu tant de temps de ressources
pour nourrir temps du moins mais le ca
des balances ville aussi comme la que
lui mais serait devenu encore plus
anxieux parce que les faux qu'il faut se
projeter vraiment foetus dans le futur
qui sillonnent intempéries 6 6 1 6 2 ce
qui
exact ce jour ses devoirs comme tu
disais tantôt de la fête voir dans
l'avenir
c'est ce qu'on appelle la perspective
temporelle - puis tu vas te rendre
compte qu'il ya des gens qui vivent
toujours dans le futur il y en a qui
vivent toujours dans le passé quand il y
en a déjà qui filles dans le préserve le
même si tout le monde nous dit faut
vivre dans le moment présent et un hub
s'appelle zimbardo et aux limites -
peut-être pautex pourquoi parce que et
déjà qu'il y ait dans le passé y en a
qui vit dans le présent accueillir dans
le futur mais rajoute une variante
maintenant est-ce que c'est positif ou
négatif des gens qui vivent dans un
passé négatif chutant à qui vit dans un
passé positif je tapais mieux dans mon
temps dans mon cas c'était mieux dans
mon temps même chose avec le futur futur
négatif tout va aller mal ou le futur
positive tout va bien je me lance d'un
avion pas de parachute sous ben ali
ok depuis le fameux moment présent dont
tout le monde se table tu peux avoir un
présent au listing est donné c'est à
dire sur tout va bien mais il ya des
gens qui ont ce qu'on appelle un présent
fataliste il ya un autre monde
quelle présence paul forme non puis le
lion montrer que c'est pas tellement
c'est dans la valence émotionnel que tu
vaux mélangé avec ta perspective
temporelle qui va déterminer si tu
souhaites malheureux amoureux et c'est
pour ça que je dis tout un le positif il
est beaucoup plus fort qu'en par
s'exclama relative parce que tu es je
pense qu en amérique du nord ont t on
est une société qui privilégie le temps
manque de pas grand chose mais on est on
est vraiment déprimé et stressé versus
d'autres sociétés qui font qu'on
pourrait penser que ce sera l'un vers ce
musical que ouais parce que je dis
toujours on est notre pire ennemi
il ya beaucoup de menaces qu'on pourrait
négocier il ya beaucoup de malades et
des fois sinon moi je le cherche passe
ma moto dans l'émission jeunesse passée
comme tant de pauvres ça me tente pas de
produit des hormones de stress on a six
ans veut pas laisser passer mon mammouth
mais pour faire ce faut vraiment être
capable d identifier celles à la hache
de guerre
exactement et comment est ce qu'en tant
que société on est capable d'identifier
des stress qu'on peut laisser passer
je sais ce que c'est pour ça que j'en
pense souvent c'est de reconnaître la
réponse de stress le problème comme je
te dis c'est que les gens attendent
toujours d'avoir la de ce qu'ils voient
sur internet quand tu regardes le stress
les images qui sont associées au stress
le y attendent d'avoir l'air d'être
savant d'allumer ils sont stressés mais
les images que dessous alors c'est pas
dix manches de stress cela c'est des
images
dépression d'anxiété piz bernina gr la
voix la dette sous l'oeil et à rentrer
automne et donc ce que je fais souvent
c'est dit c'est quoi une réponse de
stress quand n réponse de stress comme
halo vente aux livres c'est le meilleur
le mot j'ai appris mais enfin le titre
jamais ici le cheminement ici leur
rappeler entre les deux seins chez une
femme le jet loti cas ça ferme le saas
est une réponse de stress grosses comme
le bras c'est là des fois la taille de
méditer un peu le pitch du match du bon
dieu j'en ai bien il souffre parce que
tu étais toujours en train de respirer
comme ça pourquoi parce que ça c'était
poumons qui essaie d'envoyer le plus
d'oxygène possible at hemmuc pour te
donner
c'est tellement facile de reconnaître
quelqu'un vous allez peut-être rendre
compte à votre prochaine inviter
quelqu'un qui est stressé on est très
facile à détecter parce qu'il veut
toujours par lundi peu comme ça pourquoi
parce que vous avez les poupons qu'ils
envoient beaucoup de sujets une danse
quand tu connais très bien commencé ce
n'était moi je le reconnais chez moi je
les reconnais chez mes enfants que le
meilleur endroit au monde
l'épicerie non un écho depuis je pouvais
la masse world is right à l'aéroport
ouais ouais
oui moi j'arrivais toujours deux ans
avant ma soyez bon le parti comme un
autre
un autre signe de réponse aiguë de
stress le regard va se mettent à butiner
pourquoi parce que ça vous êtes en
détection de menaces déjà dit qu'elles
apportent tout d'abord comment ils vont
passer
écoute c'est de toute beauté de tout
c'est toujours serait moi je regarde sur
zuma chaleur dans limitée dans le regard
qui butinent tamalous aux ventes
la colère spontanée en est un autre
signe des petits troubles de mémoire
pourquoi parce que ce qui était
pertinent si ce qui est menacée en tout
le reste devient pas pertinent et voici
le signe que vos auditeurs vont
connaître les signes qui ne trompent
jamais l'arrivée du hamster à 2 heures
du matin j'écoute et encore une fois je
dis les gens sont terrorisés par
l'appstore cas ça fait trois jours que
l'âme story répartie et ça y est c'est
la fin puis l'a redit toujours tu penses
vraiment que le cerveau envoyé
l'abstract écurie encore aujourd'hui
l'app store c'est ton meilleur ami
pourquoi c'est quoi un hamster ou
hamster
c'est un cerveau qui a détecté de
maintenant
que ta peau encore négocier mais quand
tu sais pas qui ce qu'est ce qui te
stresse attendant amstrup à deux heures
le matin et l'autre sur le symbole
qu'est ce qui attire au lieu d'être
fermé deux heures et demie ce qui dit
l'un c'est ça ton stress à voici
maintenant ce que je dis avez vous déjà
remarqué que votre hamster hip hop
jusqu'à toi de ton cerveau et positives
menées par d'autres choses moi la queue
toute la journée que dissimule son
cerveau avec un google doodle poule où
est l'erreur de m on doit ces plaintes
peuvent être tentés mammoth en dessous
du tapis puis vont rester là puis ça va
être court et plus tu vas regretter la
juriste de jake sully un soupçon tout
abus d'horreur mais clos soit couche et
là c'est la première fois de la journée
conservons et pau stimuler et sachez
monsieur que votre cerveau des tests ne
pas être stimulé la preuve au réveil
haïssent et là c'est la première fois de
la journée que ton cerveau et posthume
les plus louches pensez vous sincèrement
que votre cerveau dont la tâche première
est d'assurer la survie de l'espèce qui
va vous laisser vous endormez sans garde
en dessous du tapis serait pas une coupe
de même autres quitteront jamais et donc
qu'est ce qui va lever tôt et il va vous
réactivez un moment de la journée le
bayer c'est parti puis et deux autres
humains se sait si ça pour vous empêcher
de vous endormez si vous étiez bien
fatigué vous endormez plus de
soudainement lui ce réveil mais quand
l'un d'eux non détection menaces très
vite ma pensée est souvent on est
tellement terrorisée congèle pour fait
plus rien ouais moi je me suis j'ai eu
un gros stress est gros gros il ya une
coupe de moins 3 jours en ligne à 2
heures du matin dans mon lit les deux
ouvert moi j'ai une grosse marge de ce
soir nous et là j'ai deux choix voici ce
que je vais vous dit j'ai deux choix je
m'élève cheval déconstruit je voudrais
construire dont on finit par leur sortie
ils se remettront ça se fait comme
absent une faillite m papillon ou si on
a fait aussi un petit programme de
e-learning qui s'appelle stress et
compagnie que tu peux le faire paraître
internet mais qu'apprend de feuilles et
chris benarroch je te regarde sur des
sites web que j'ai le toilettes soit le
world la tête de déconstruire 2 heures
du matin me tente pas tout mais c'est
mon truc
comment fait on chantait de temps ce
matin paul bert
sam mucho des trucs pour calmer un
hamster le temps qu après cette puce
autre chose pour ça je promène mon chez
moi parce que mon film parle pas avec
moi je déconstruis je laisse pas pu
monster le jo si jamais l'on sait mais
ne dit pas pour le parent pauvre ça
j'aurais cherché - le sommet dans une
voix pop et de soul mais bref deux
heures du matin et jamais dans ton lit
tu veux pas d construit des coûts de la
musique avec des paroles
pourquoi peut-être de savoir si vous
êtes des athlètes la vie si vous le
savez très bien bonne compétition vous
deviez le faire parce que ça vous est
incapable de la misère à traiter deux
tâches en même temps qu'ils utilisent
les mêmes ressources au ton âme street à
part si tu écoute de la musique avec des
paroles surtout c'est des paroles tu
connais pas déjà d'un nouvel tout est
ton cerveau va être attiré par ce temps
sur votre club med soit au moins tu
dormiras petit paumé thibault ramasser
un niveau de sommeil était sous sommeil
qui au moins tu seras mans sera pas trop
ram a gagné le lendemain la brune
capable de passer à travers mais c'est
encore un petit peu mettre les pouces
est en dessous tu es belle lendemain
faute et prend des tons shield ça paye
ton hamster et ce dans le fond c'est
qu'on est sûr simuler finalement depuis
le temps de faire
l'intériorisation ou de ce travail le
confesse de tête le savent exactement
puis on est très bon c'est le canton une
émotion négative que soient les
supprimer des dons à l'épaule à la roue
essayer de l'algérie mais on n'est pas
mal non plus il ya plus de moments en
fait c'est avant d'aller chez le
dentiste en venant salles d'attentes pis
tu as aussi essentielle
maintenant il est plus ce moment-là de
juste à être nullement une lettre à 6 pi
attendre le 6 et le pas dans cette
affaire c'est comme il tout le temps une
stylisation je t'aime excuse d une
source de stress qui est assez évidente
dans ma vie c'est le temps la relation
avec le temps un fake moutons 15,5 chut
chut limite pour être un rendez vous un
endroit si le plus gros stress hors de
ma ville
quand je sens que j'ai une période
courte moi je suggère à partir 15 buts
d'avancé tout le temps le ticket du
temps il fallait que je parte le dessus
puis
il ya tu dis tu répandue c'est une autre
relation que le temps ce que c'est
quelque chose qui est étudiée ça défend
déjà mais pour la majorité des gens le
truc en jeu je prenais pas de
questionnaire parce que tout le monde
pense que le stress et la pression du
temps là on sent stressée quand on n'a
pas le temps de faire les choses qu'on
voudrait faire et pourtant le stress
c'est pas la pression du stade
mais le stress que tu vis avec la
pression du temps c'est quoi la pression
du temps la pression du temps ce n'est
rien d'autre qu'une perte de contrôle
sur ton temps - la même façon que tu
peux perdre le contrôle sur ta famille
des finances est ton couple etc et donc
ta relation au temps 7 ce sens du
contrôle sur le temps mais pour toi
c'est un gros stress à qui je donne un
exemple je te ressemble beaucoup
là-dessus ce sable côte pendant mon auto
le plus jeune je donne un coup au plus
haut depuis 15 minutes d'avancé que moi
j'ai réglé mon problème je connais tous
les cafés de la ville de montréal
je me dis moi je pars deux heures damas
puis ça me tente plus très sec soit
juste un exemple parfait sans se
stresser horloge capable de gérer de la
mainmise est sûr et certain que je vais
algérie - temps j'arrive deux heures
pour prendre du café plus le jeu peut
planter courriel partout tu peux
travailler sur un travail n'importe où
puis à partir de ce moment là parce que
je t'ai tanné d'être monotone j moins
qu'actuellement
les glaciers se traite à la course
partout mais effectivement ce mets ton
si on élargit un petit peu là le sujet
en se disant analysons les stresseurs
parce que beaucoup de stresseurs qu'on
peut contrôler ou finale
une fois que les tulles et déconstruite
laitue les mains sur table tu réalises
lesquels tu peux contrôler lesquels tu
peux pas obtus tu enlèves que demandent
trois corps devant bandits même plus ce
sont des stress relatif oubli paul je
veux aller plus loin ces districts
relatif oui tu peux crime bien plus que
seuls 15% exemple par contre georges
donne une conférence la madame est fort
chez elle attend même pas la situer leur
période de questions madame les pieds
quand même joué pour le jeune enfant
leucémie ça se peut qu'ils m'en voudrez
pas à croire que c'est un stress relatif
sur le contrôle on s'entend dessus et je
lui répondu madame absolument ya encore
des stress absolu de nos jours il a
maladie d'un enfant maladie
potentiellement incurable et non mais je
vais vous parler de l'étude du docteur
mason en 1968
voici l'étude ils se sont dit les
parents des enfants très malades qui
peuvent pourrir doivent être est ce un
bon jour on voit les étudier et ils ont
observé que beaucoup beaucoup de parents
tombé malade parce que ça affecte le
système immunitaire le stress quand
leurs enfants étaient très très très
malade vous finissiez par tomber malades
eux-mêmes à la longue mais il y avait un
certain pourcentage de pain pas du tout
et donc qu'ils ont étudié ses parents
lui ont dit que c'est qu'ils ont en
commun séparant lolliot accepte le feu
n'ont pas de contrôle des noms que sion
pour s'en sortir ils sont rentrés aucune
des caractéristiques grosse tête d'ataï
avait pas internet où se mêlent ayant
embarqué publics travaillent dans des
revues puis il est toujours d'affaler
journaux plus y arriver puis dit aux
médecins en jeu c'est cas clinique mayo
quelque chose pour la lui simin mon
enfant et donc il s'est informé ses
formes et ses formes et qu'est ce qui
faisait ses parents lancent un format
ils diminuaient l'imprévisibilité de la
maladie ils augmentaient leur répression
c'est pour ça que je désirais pas
seulement impression d'avoir le contrôle
y aurait jamais le contrôle sa maladie
du petit mais il y avait les pressions
de contrôler quelque chose là dedans et
pour eux c'était juste assez pour
empêcher les hormones de stress
d'affecter leurs synonymes l'impression
de contrôler peu imaginent réduire le
stress mais aussi la prise de conscience
qu'on n'a pas le contrôle est un exemple
mais ton et mettons comprend la kfw dans
ce moment là dessus j'ai aucun contrôle
puis mettons que tu stresses parce que
tu te dis je
j'ai dû contrôler ce qu'est ce que je
peux faire pis mais moi la minute mais
tant que tu dis je peux rien faire
rapport écouter ce qu'on me dit ouah
mettons le pij et aucun contrôle malade
tu enlèves un petit peu là ce stress
l'on dit dans un autre bon ouais bah
c'est ce qui bénéficie la poste mais je
veux tel pouce à ceux qui vont sortir de
cette pandémie stress chronique comme je
le dis pour tout le monde comme on n'a
jamais vu un de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité y avait eu un stress assez
long pour tout les humains
en tête ceux qui vont s'en sortir ce
sont ceux qui vont accepter de s'adapter
le stress ça existe pour assurer la
survie de l'espèce
on survit parce qu'on s'adapte et donc
s'adapter accepté de s'adapter succès ça
que c'est exactement ce que tu sais je
dis toujours faut voir les stresseurs
comme un gros bloc que la vie des poses
devant fin qu'à dépose un groupe puis on
m'a jeté habitude d'aller sur le mont
petit chemin plongera dans le bloc mais
j'ai deux choix je peux dire oui on
saigne heureuse pour un règlement
louvain où ben je recule un peu plus je
me dis que je peux penser à gauche ou à
droite ceux qui acceptent de s'adapter
ceux qui acceptent que les choses ne
sont plus comme avant donc on fait
d'autres choses c'est eux qui vont s'en
sortir sans trop de séquelles par contre
voici la règle quand on se décide de
s'adapter avec moi le lot à chaque jour
jose utilise le mois d'adaptation - trop
on se donne des cocos on s'adapte on
s'adore voici leur candidate choisit de
t'adapter pas c'est un choix tu dois
accepter de faire des erreurs
le cerveau humain ne peut pas apprendre
sans faire d'erreurs et c'est parce
qu'on a appris qu on s'est adapté tant
leur donner un exemple avant tu pouvais
faire ta comptabilité tranquille se
fendrait du matin il pleut des plus
capable parce que des colloques sont
debout de bonheur factice que je vais
essayer autre chose
le t'essayes plus ça marche pas parce
que je portais colloque sont encore là
et cetera bas au lieu de pet en position
foetale par ari puis dhiba au moins ça a
duré trois jours je vais essayer
d'autres choses qui auraient essayé
d'autres choses parce que je vais
m'adapter
ceux qui vont être rigide dans leurs
pensées qui vont diminuer les coûts de
fonds communs ils vont souffrir le
martyre c'est exactement c'est donc
c'est plus qu'on voit aussi quasiment
neutre autour de soins
c'est le paradoxe l'histoire que je
raconte est sûre la mama avec l'enfant
du scénic mais si les parents qui vont
faire finalement leurs propres
recherches je mets des guillemets parce
que c'est un terme qu'on n'entend pas
mal ces temps-ci mais justement j'ai
l'impression qui est en ce moment dans
le contexte de la pandémie c'est les
gens qui font leurs propres recherches
c'est une réponse au stress moment au
stress que la pandémie du procureur mais
dans l'information ces informations ont
été on la connaît pas toutes encore pu y
en a tellement de mauvaises que
justement c'est d'essayer de trouver du
contrôle que de halle est grugé
d'information à gauche à droite mais
finalement qui est les poches et passe
juste sous va donc le ca le finalement
vouloir prendre le contrôle l'impression
qu'on se barre à terre damart finalement
d'ascama écoute ya jamais eu autant
d'informations qui circulent loin moi
j'ai coaché pas quoi te réponde à ça
parce que l'euro c'est beau c'est moi je
peux dire un enfer je la reconnais moi
la réponse de stress quand je lis quand
je lis de koala qui s'abat jeu comme la
neige comme ya de quoi il ya de quoi là
dedans bon on devrait capable de faire
la part des choses même aussi chiante
ific des fautes de la misère à savoir
qu'est ce qui est consommé nationale
qu'est ce qu'il est publié avec cette
erreur c'est tellement bien fait là mais
je me dis que je vais pas commencer à
lire juste du fleur bleue etc
mais on est capable d'avoir une pensée
objective sans qu'elles soient
nécessairement épeurante je pense que si
on fait juste la différence
est ce que ces objectifs quand
j'enseigne à l'université à mes
étudiants la pensée critique
je leur dis toujours la pensée critique
c'est pas la pensée négative alliant
n'exprimait d'enseigner ou signés ou qui
pensent qu'ils sont intelligents
c'est teigneuse autour de douai c'est
cela la pensée critique c'est de la
capacité à dire c'est niaiseux à cause
d'eux et c'est beau à cause de ses tapas
et de côté ce pont de pensée critique et
donc c'est ce que j'essaye de chercher
moi je me dis j'ai besoin des deux côtés
est ce que ces objectifs ou c'est juste
sensationnaliste et c'est le posa
réponse est simple on la pop y ont posé
hier la question à ce que le stress peut
amener des questions étaient est il des
conspirationnistes jeudi de problème
les conspirationnistes car stationné
pour un mec sur la bonne voie d'être
normale pour conspirationnistes dans la
poésie étudiés est ce que est ce qu'il
ya une manière maintenant je pense les
questions je peux c'est hier dans une
entrevue que j'avais entendu la question
on peut dessus je peux aller chez le
médecin que je pense je suis stressé et
pimmel mesure petit kit extrait cia
sur dix le août et ce tracé à tulle
savoir objectivement comment je
commençais nous dans nos labos on le
sait pas ce qu'on mesure dans les
hormones de stress financier un paquet
d'affaires ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on essaye de convaincre les médecins
qu'on aurait des capacités de teck
capable de mesurer ce qu'on appelle le
poids le statique c'est à dire à quel
point tu es rendu loin dans ton stress
mais le plus dur en sciences suisse et
pas de découvrir quelque chose c'est de
l'implanter samedi ouverte le puits de
convaincre des cliniciens de convaincre
des gens que tu as découverte aurait
potentiellement impôts ci a pas d'argent
ce siège
à ce moment là ça va être peut y est peu
intéressant soit-il qui va descendre au
niveau du stress en ce moment encore le
temps tu peux par contre les américains
et les autres vont toujours plus vite
chez certains sites web on peut mesurer
pourquoi le statique aux états unis puis
les montants dire à voix - échantillon
de simples ils vont mesurer toutes
sortes d'affaires sauf que tu vas être
comparés aux normes américaines pour se
hisser sur hull vie avec tout ce que
tout ce que tu connais sur le stress
avec toutes les études le coût est
condamnée dans la connaissance qui est
ce que justement tu changerais dans la
monarque compteront demain matin
justement tu pouvais apprendre
maintenant les médecins font lts ou
maintenant on instaure site ont fait ce
qu est ce qu est ce qu est ce que tu es
conception des stress hydriques la pêche
jour est d'abord et avant tout les
oublie la mesure les prêts conception
des prêts conception de ce que je disais
notre définition du stress le
j'arrêterai les prêts conception
négative puis je commencerai serait d
écoute si j'avais les moyens le chevet d
d d une chose de communication pour dire
que le stress peut avoir des effets
aussi positif est que votre donner un
exemple juste que tu comprennes
collègues allemands aux états unis fait
une étude chez des enfants deux groupes
les stress perçu devant mesurer la
mémoire wright premier groupe idiot
qu'est le logement titre et c'est là que
le nul au qatar marguelov ne le sait sur
l'estrie cependant soyez stress
musulmans l'autre groupe des petits
enfants et leur dit je vais stresser
petit les papillons dedans tant aux
angles du papillon le centre et stress
qui se connaît le résultat
temps quand il leur disait d eddie c d e
ne désarmant de stress vont augmenter la
mémoire fait que les mots continue son
lent et pourtant tellement qui sont
connotés négativement aux idées mars qui
y mène le servent à détecter des menaces
donc juste de réapprendre aux gens que
le stress c'est vraiment là que je
mettrai mon argent sur cette nouvelle
génération qui s'en vient puis je dire
aux parents arrêtés fermez vos boîtes à
l'heure du souper
vous avez aucune idée de ce qu un enfant
peut apprendre à table de cuisine sur
l'heure du souper
papa maman sera conclue journée ça
écoute c'est ça faire le jeu et dans les
chicanes et aussi qu'ils avaient avec
quelqu'un on travaille dit vous êtes à
table
ça c'est un code dans cette nouvelle
génération l'eau qui s'en vient puis je
me dis bien si on parle aux jeunes
peut-être qu'ils m'ont dit au monde
franchement ça vole moi je me suis on a
fait un programme qui s'appelle des
stress et progresse dans les écoles
pendant montrer je prends des rentiers à
75 mille jeunes qui ont eu de programme
parce qu on forme les professeurs qui
forment les jeunes après puis apparaît
qui m'apaise d'un financiers td
financial broker il m'appelle et d'îlots
madame di piave vous surprise a du coup
perdu mon fils c'est johnny que neuf
monfils s'il ne parle pas beaucoup
puis c'est le soir au souper puis je
raconte ma journée par stressante à ma
femme puis je sais pas pourquoi je
stresse il
je raconte ma journée plemons fait ce
qu'il dit pas un mot soudainement parler
du buzz c'est sur mon papa que c'est
stressant ces nouveaux imprévisible taux
plein contrôle j'ai compris les gens
peut-être parce que quand des
apprentissages tellement intégré à l'âge
des parents je me dis c'est dur à
défendre
choquée moi pas ultra stressée qu'il ne
jamais nommer pleut jamais reconnu
convaincu t mais il ya une chose par
exemple que mes parents on fit qui se
dira merci je m'étonne je les ai jamais
vus se chicaner devant moi mais ils sont
sûrement jusqu'à n'écartait pas le temps
de jeu sans doute le sûrement sauf que
tu es j'imagine un foyer justement où
est ce que un jeune très toujours témoin
de tout ce qui se dit en parlant livre
sur les parents le puits se cherche
alors un chercheur qui a étudié ça toute
sa vie puis disait c'est une erreur de
penser que de rester ensemble à tout
prix si vous restez ensemble et vous
chicaner vous allez le mag année c'est
sûr ensemble ces soul puis aussi de
maintenant comprend les parents qui qui
se force à rester ensemble ça fait juste
décuplée aussi eux mêmes leur c'est
encore pire pour tout le monde mais
c'est pour ça que je trouve ça tellement
abondants une des conférences je pense
qu'on en a pas même si peu tantôt métier
de tilly parra qui quitta riche bien et
mon enfant est donc stressé qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour que ça me stresse
ebay commence par travailler surtout a
construit ce après son lot de règle ici
on parle de ses deux enfants parce qu'il
était stressé parce que toi aussi pour
ça que j'ai écrit le livre à chacun son
stress justement les effets débordement
du stress parental sur les enfants pour
peser la paire à la première à passer
comme dans l'avion en cas l'hôtesse de
l'air d'ici silien dépressurisation de
l'appareil et que le masque dont est
elle sur vous un an les mettre sur vos
enfants parce que je vais passage vicat
rien je disais si tu arrives tu es tout
à stresser ton flow je sais pas quand il
atteint le mais il faut juste il faut
juste apprendre maintenant depuis tantôt
en sont maintenant je comprends beaucoup
l'idée de
déstigmatiser le stress puis de rendre
ce de changer un petit peu la façon avec
laquelle on l'a bord mais depuis tantôt
on parle de stress d'effets négatifs du
site risque de vouloir ne pas
transmettre le stress aux enfants mais
si on laborde de l'aude balle sur le
prendre l'autre bord comparé avec le
prix conçus que le stress est pas
nécessairement négatif comment est ce
que en fait est ce que c'est possible de
faire un bon enseignement du stress à la
maison puis si oui pour notamment la
maison mais dans notre entourage est
tout petit oui comment est-ce que c'est
sûr matérialisent premièrement arrêté
d'en avoir par des plots leur art
ok écoute le cas il va te faire mal le
stress il va te dit tu vois le savoir
aux besoins de mode pour te le dise il
doit le savoir rien de fait d'accident
tombaient entre de bleury bio banalité
jeudi de soi le savent et donc moi je
dis souvent si à autun d'enfants inclut
aujourd'hui c'est que peut-être
pensez-y deux minutes que la terre
revenons à ton afin de chauves-souris
d'accord l'apprentissage de par mois je
pense qu un conditionnement pas sur le
stress lors qu est la première fois qu
il dispute la 83 ans a une réponse de
trottoirs de gucht avait eu une réponse
de stress à 3 4 1 le 6 a jamais personne
qui vous a dit qu'ils étaient normales
mais c'est ce qui va faire que vous
allez avoir l'impression que je pense
que je suis la seule main comment on
fait sa rentrée à la maternelle libano
26e que de mal au ventre moncoucou ben
oui c'est sûr rien à faire c'est surtout
ramalho bambins qui courait parce que ça
ça me dit que tu es plus réveillé tout
le plus rêver de la gagne je peux te le
jurer et dans 2 d'enlever la part liée à
cette réponse de stress là et quand il
ya des thérapies spo des thérapies mais
ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est que il
faut activer le système physique des
jeunes au quai d'en face au tc
trampoline de fasozine trampoline je
veux créer la même affaire que c'est
était stressé tonka va battre vite et
c'est pour que goethe habitués à
négocier sur tarek de capoter quand tu
reçois ce message le losc correct on
peut mourir lors pas la fin du monde
bleu tout juste une réponse d'activation
catécholamines airship c'est tout le
pays c'est ton cerveau qui dit ban
l'homme était tout à fait capable je
pense que le bout yann menaces sont le
tout encoder mais le boot est capable de
gérer ça il ya personne qui nous le
disent certes est sûre c'est le bout qui
manque t capable de gérer son on a
survécu aux m'importe que c'est le bout
qui dans l'inconscient en fait c'est
pour inventer une déconstruction sociale
en fait parce que dans l'inconscient le
pays capable d'en sortir et est même pas
une question tu sais c'est un agissement
qui venait naturellement je me dis oui
et puis moi je pense qu'il ya plein de
gens qui ont fait bien de l'argent en
pathologie sans le stress sans des
pseudo-thérapies disciple de sauter des
fois je regarde aux états unis par
exemple ce campus palois s'est fait que
la théologie tout parce que pour que ta
gti buzz c'est à moi si je mourais une
clinique antistress le site pilule
contre l'astra sinon ça s'appelle la vie
pierre n'aurait même si à la ville je la
mettrais pur mensonge dans le jeu mais
non mais non ça s'appelle la vie psy
correct puis chaque adversité damois
jadida mais enfin toulon dans chaque
adversité ya toujours une opportunité
rappelle dans chaque adversité il ya
toujours une opportunité tout un tout en
un
on va sortir de cette pandémie on va se
dire et à cette heure on peut faire des
meetings zoom cet objet prendre de tout
le monde il va toujours y avoir quelque
chose c'est ce qu'assure la survie des
enfants dans votre démarche un délai
avec le string et battiston face au
scrabble et 10 passes est-ce que tu
seras tu attendais tellement gagner le
jour la pause est un bon petit flynn au
prix d'un savant tabac par exemple
j'étais est comme ça a été long je
revenais pas juste de moi plus que
quiconque
incapable j'aiderai comment ça joue
scrabble avec lui mais c'est fascinant
comme comme diane question tu m'as pas
poser en victime de ce parti non mais tu
as peu
je l'en tête depuis tantôt encore puis
on va y revenir mais je suis une enfant
avant d'aller à cette question là
quelqu'un qui nous écoutent pas ce que
c'est que de me dis tantôt c'est facile
à dire très difficile à faire t2 de
réaliser que tous les tous les obstacles
on peut les surmonter que le stress
c'est quelque chose que tu peux
contrôler mais il ya souvent un monde
qui nous écoutent autrement qui entre
dans la période dans laquelle on vit ou
dans leur vie en général sont en
détresse en détresse puis paralysé par
ce bien capable de faire de se distancer
de la situation pour analyser qui est
finalement c'est un stress qui va se
terminer puis qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
faire ces gens le tir c'est quoi c'est
quoi les recours est ce que tu peux
avoir de l'aide de gestion stress et ce
qui est du monde qui font se commet ce
que tu peux t'en sortir ou du moins en
termine une une solution par toi même
excuse qu'est ce qu'on fait est que tu
peu d'écho tarder on peut déconstruire
construite sur mon ski est ce que tu as
un excellent début si vous avez jamais
fait l'expérience déjà commencé au début
je te nique à tous et a dit qu'il aimait
ce que tu décris je peux parler de ceux
des psychologues sur ce jeu du nord ce
que tu décris c'est la difficulté que
l'humain année âgés à réguler qu'on
appelle une émotion
ok on est super bonne zone pour réguler
une émotion positive on aime ce qui est
même optique on n'est pas bon pour
négocier une émotion négative quand
l'humain à une émotion négative c'est
comme s'ils avaient une patate chaude
demain il sait pas quoi faire avec
plaisir débarrasser du sud parce que
nous aurons le temps d'y couler c'est
critique stérile sur la fin et pourtant
c'est ce qu'il faudrait pas faire et je
leur dis toujours une émotion négative
ça même affaire que la douleur à la
douleur parfois même pas savoir la
douleur non mais à quoi ça sert la
douleur ça ça rasait enlève ta main du
point c'est chaud on est de la même
façon c'est quoi une émotion négative
une émotion négative ce n'est rien
d'autre que ton cerveau qui a détecté un
deux puis qui dit coûte un noeud dans ta
vie quelque chose maintenant revenons la
doublant quand brûle pas tu as mal
qu'est ce que tu vas faire prendre la
douleur soit coupée
non tu vas à temps mais pourquoi d'abord
quand tu as une émotion négative sur
tout le monde vante de chanteuse cherche
c'est la beauté du monde et donc gens
parlent d'anti pull à chacun son stress
la meilleure façon c'est de faire la
même affaire qu'avec la douleur rien le
haut de gamme g pas dire y est après
deux semaines je dis rien après quand
est t'il aujourd'hui l'hôtel mauvaise
journée tellement et journée
l'institution qui on a envie que pitié
pour son nom sphérier et maintenant
regarder ce qu'est ce que je veux les
chercheurs ont commencé à étudier les
émotions négatives qui ont dit et j'aime
pas ça des émotions négatives ils
capotent
mais combien de temps ça dure parce que
des fois quand tu es dans l'émotion
négative ça y est le plus heureux parce
que mon bébé bus va lui fit plus wii lot
17 milliard d'âmes en avant mais lyon
dijon
toujours au rayon du comité ces deux et
on étudie vin et de cette émotion
komitas à deux lots gildas à chacun son
stress j'ai fait le tableau des durées
d'émotions négatives
celle qui dure le plus longtemps la
colère est à dieu maximum 48 ans donc
voici moi je peux jurer que kg une pige
d'année des journées d'arc à qui il
parle moins j'essaye même pas de savoir
pourquoi je commence et je ne fais rien
à qui je fais ça depuis un an et demi
puis je t'aime je pas montré aujourd'hui
au moins ça fonctionne que si jamais
rien sera pas mort puis je vais
l'annoncer gens revenir à sa tante
aujourd'hui par exemple à mes enfants
quand j'habitais avec un autre le moment
peut-être bolton a demandé quelque chose
donc le moment vos problèmes et donc
plus je parle de taille me suis jamais
rendu à plus que 38 et le mont bellevue
matin l'homme nous l'une plus je me
trouve pas un vote mais je n'y ai fait
mon lot c'est juste l'émotion comme un
vieux qui s'est en allé d'un coup
maintenant
citons émotions négatives de suite
depuis deux mois et qui le tenait qu
cela vole le temps besoin d'aller
chercher de l'aide en psychothérapie etc
mais vous seriez étonnés de voir le
nombre de fois qu'elle d'émotion volant
chez donc à rien faire est une option
maintenant tu dis non non je peux rien
faire dans une coupe de trucs
un enfant qui fonctionne admirablement
bien on ne sait pas pourquoi c'est nommé
l'émotion on a beau apprécier
il ya prennent soudain écoles
aujourd'hui m'ont dit qu'on n'est pas
bon ça on a appris la trigonométrie
plaisir aux croyances à vol
on a pour après ça je trouve ça dommage
quand même nommé l'émotion puis quand je
dis mais madame et l'émotion nomme
l'émotion quand tu dis à quelqu'un qui
est en émotions négatives du rock &
noble émotions la première affaire qui
vont faire ça va être
je vois bien où je tends rage noire là
c'est beau et laid ce que je faisais par
exemple une maison enfin j'ai
pousse-pousse avait dit voit plus loin
et enlève des plus grandes baisses qui
m'a enlevé georges d'engager deux mois
c'est beaucoup ce jeu contrarié ok on
continue parce je frenche est ok
pourquoi je suis gêné plus d'une
rencontre que te donner un commentaire
que cet objet et nesat a contrarié de
finale régionale et nous faut quelque
chose
arrête pas besoin de savoir pourquoi tu
as été génial espères tu vas voir que
plus du mono mais plus ça va ouvrir tout
cas je te disais tu étais jamais un rôle
plus à vouvry fait comment juste parfait
ce qui annonce des couleurs on parle pas
assez des sceaux chu en réjouis
aujourd'hui te bat des candidatures et
donc on va faire ce genre la deuxième
affaire tu peux faire qui fonctionne
bien écrit comme un tuteur peau à 60
minutes à leur deal à main pourquoi pas
ce qu'on écrit moins vite qu'on pense et
ça ralentit la homestory par plus de
faisais un book cursive écoute foutent
de notre mandat et pour ralentir à
l'entièreté aux acheteurs il ya des
chercheurs qui vont même proposé de ne
pas se relever parce que si tu te relis
timoré par activer ce qu'on appelle une
rumination tu fais juste le chantier et
c'est ce qui va faire que les émotions
négatives
il faut arrêter paniquer avec une
émotion est native on en a besoin de ses
émotions négatives l'eau c'est ce qui
faisait qu'on était capable de survie
c'est ça qui fait qu'on se dit je pense
le plus beau job ou je sais pas quoi
ôter il faut qu'on se le dise à un
moment donné ont pas besoin de le crier
sur les réseaux sociaux nécessairement
puis on se dit mais c'est sûr que si ça
perdure dans le temps et là je veux
juste faire un petit aparté d'achat 15
ans par un bond du stress le dernier
j'ai rajouté beaucoup de chapitres sur
ce que j'appelle les tunnels noirs
dépression eut cité volante
moi j'appelle ça des tina non on a tous
si vous êtes jeunes les garçons chez eux
que vous avez tous quand même rentrer
dans le dinosaure un jour on note au sus
aux coûts dont je suis déprimé burn out
etc
puis on disait une personne sur quatre
qui va avoir un trouble mental du pauvre
et ses 8 sur 10
les études qui disent eur sur 4 parce
qu'ils avaient mesurer jusqu'à un moment
donné de leur vie puis des chercheurs
quant aux autres obesity pendant 30 puis
montrent que sur 30 ans et 8 passes et
puis je mets une citation ladakh et bien
importante avoir un désordre mental
à un moment donné de sa vie est la norme
et pas l'exception mais quand est né le
départ 1 ils se sont tus dit monfils le
n y aura jamais une infection aux
oreilles de sa vie mais non et pourquoi
d'abord on dit monfils a rejoint petit
robin veut ça et donc c'est tout à fait
normal qu'il ya des gens qui rentrent
dans des tunnels noirs qui vont s'en
sortir avec l'aide de la médication ou
avec l'aide la psychothérapie ou avec
100 m
il ya plein de gens qui s'en sortent
sans z pire sens d'un noir m a donné
puis avoir rattrapé un autre danseur
puis voilà donc c'est sûr que quand il
disait qu'il loge dans un sinan wadhams
le puits la lumière au bout du tunnel
quand tu te trompes et claude legault
vainqueur l'as roma a le oui je pense
qu'on devrait j'en parle dans le livre
aussi de quel genre des d'aller chercher
parce que moi ce qui m'énerve quatre
fois chez le médecin il va donner des
entités passage où vrombissent collègues
qui ont fait ce commun on vous
recommande qu'on cherche quoi comme
psychologue et donc j'ai dit dans ce
livre j'ai vraiment tout mis en dix ans
commettent souvent faire pour aller sur
le site de l'ordre des psychologues du
québec on se dit bon compte exactement
celui qui est bon pour toi tu pues posez
vous une question quand vous voulez
aller voir un psy qui pour moi même si
l'objet est élevé mes enfants comme ça
c'est l'équivalent d'un coach soit pour
nous un petit bassin être augmentée qui
soit voir un psy passe tu veux garder ta
sentimentale d'un coach du reste en
santé et donc la question bien
importante à se poser c'est je veux
turgot une fille parce que ce qui est
important en thérapie c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'alliance thérapeutique non ce
magazine un psy comment ce magazine en
moins de blanc - il est tout à fait
possible qui est sûre à long beach art
culinaire ne s'immisce paulo c'est pas
fort du psi a juste pas d'alliance en
dessous d'eux change de psy puis je vois
chercher un jusqu'à temps que tu tombes
sur un seul à le savoir soit sorti et
autres à wii continue ça va marcher site
serait ce dans une thérapie propos
l'alliance thérapeutique
c'est juste une question de chimie du
pardon argent puisse ebay faut vraiment
se demande jeudi par largo brune fait
dépendamment du problème dépendamment de
peu importe il faut que tu as tout
compris ça
en général tu en as pour ton argent
avant de te laisser partir ces
fascinants sur ce que je continuerai
pendant des heures la question était de
savoir quelle est la différence entre un
gars une fille quand bien tant de
questions entre les sexes et les genres
sur comment contrôler on va partir au
micro et macro j'amène mon la bodega des
filles que je laisse très cyclique et
plus réactif au stress légaux les faits
j'ai tendance à dire lego lego sont six
fois plus réactif six fois ouais j'ai
tellement nous a restreint ses défis aux
strass et des filles sympas dans le les
filles vont rapporter plus de stress
subjectif mais quand une mesure
physiologiquement selig le stress voire
aux mineurs huawei est donc les
chercheurs avaient dit baye le jour
aller plus loin parce que c'est trop
drôle et je vous laisserai sur ces
paroles mais les chercheurs ont dû
baisse pour ce que les hommes ont plus
de maladies cardiovasculaires mais c'est
vrai d'abord même puis deuxièmement les
femmes sont plus déprimées fx possible
que ce soit avec ses licences ont plus
de bruit
2 pour 1 ça commence à nous laissant ce
soin est ici les chercheurs allemands
qui avaient montré que les hommes
étaient plus réactif au stress
qu'engendre est que les gens cherchent à
la main je suppose c'est mieux sauter
j'ai dit bon ça doit dépendre d'eux
d'autres facteurs puis un des facteurs
qu'on sait qu'ils vont diminuer le
stress c'est ce qu'on appelle le soutien
social quand ils stressent il reste
possible de sol trop féminine appelle
des dom duff quelque chose à votre
empêché de ruminer 5 les chercheurs
allemands en fait la lutte l'étudiant
qui on va regarder si la différence
hommes femmes est encore flou car on
donne soutien social à la personne avant
de la stresser avec la première étude
qui ont fait et ont dit aux hommes
amener votre épouse pour vous donner du
soutien social avant d'être exposée au
stress puis 10 ou femme emmener votre
goût pour vous donner du soutien social
avant d'être c'est un fake là ils font
ça lorsqu'on observe c'est que les
résultats avaient de base c'est
maintenant à madame qui frustrés c'est
que monsieur dans ce que ça dit c'est
que monsieur quand sa femme est là pour
lui donner du soutien ça diminue sa
réactivité au stress et madame car ce
sont marie ça augmente sérieux
congrès qu'à amsterdam ac les allemands
jugent le les gars vous allez publier
sur vous allez vous retrouver dans le
times magazine a pas de vous expliquer
comment tu expliques ça j'étais c'était
juste un effet de 6 et une femme ils ont
qui vont voir faire l'étude là qui
refont les tubes cette fois ci avec déjà
du même sexe donc aux hommes et dise
amen tomber ce tome 2 blocks pour te
donner du soutien avant d'être stressé
pour fermer 10 amener votre bestiole
deux filles pour et servier comme
c'était chez les hommes qui sont trois
fois plus et soient plus réactifs que
stress que les femmes donc ce que ça
veut dire c'est que les hommes et les
femmes ne bénéficient pas des mêmes
personnes en temps de stress monsieur
sans beaucoup bénéficié du support de sa
copine tandis que les faits ils vont
beaucoup beaucoup bénéficient du soir
alors que plus de leurs papiers doucy
déjà du même sexe hockey et donc ça a
roulé pendant bb long d'un puits parler
de ce résultat le pendant dix ans peut
mener je promenais mon chien et le chat
minutes choses qui marchent pas là
dedans parce que stress égale survie de
l'espèce rails on recommence monsieur
quand sa femme est l'os à diminuer son
stress
madame car son mari et la salle augment
question à 200 mille dollars
à quoi servent les époux en termes de
stress avoir mis le mammouth
je sais pas du compère jeux d'hiver il
faut briques servent à quelque chose il
faut qu'on cesse et donc je me suis
toujours posé ces questions le payement
de neige tombe sur un article d'un gagne
deux chercheurs américains qui ont
répondu à la question ils sont posé la
même question à quoi servent 18 pouces
qui servent à quelque chose est sûre
mois des bonnes nouvelles pour vous ôter
garçons ça qui ont fait l'étude y ont
pris trois groupes de femmes le premier
groupe le mari était juste là il faisait
rien c'est juste ça présente plus le
stress madame laure groupe le mari est l
api lui donnait du soutien sous forme
verbale comme dans les deux autres
premières études ça va bien aller mon
amour de confiance en toi et dans
trosième groupe monsieur donnait du
soutient madame sous forme physique par
un message aux épaules et les résultats
que j'ai bien sûr encadré dans ma
cuisine ont montré que seul le massage
aux épaules diminuer le stress de madame
donc le rôle de monsieur c'est vraiment
pas verbal
napa physique et dans par amour du
stress je le dis carrément bon messieurs
à chaque fois le dit soit vous vous
demandez mon petit chou ce massage c'est
n'importe quoi de physique est ce qu'une
relation sexuelle pourrait déstresser
madame tout porte à croire que oui à des
études ont montré magie n'est qu'il ya
même des gens qui font ça
assurez-vous que madame mes potes déjà
stressés par les tiap et tout se passe
que le ça fonctionnera pas mais voyez
comment sinon pas la vaisselle utilisée
je commencerai par le passage aux
épaules mais vraiment donc les
différences sont l'homme et sont assez
surface mais tant qu'on prend trois
minutes juste pour pousser cette
question lui a un peu plus loin de
petits et vidéo j'avais vu je pense qui
date de 2015 sur youtube ou escales afin
qu'ils parlent aussi de l'identité de
genre et d'orientation sexuelle
vous savez un effet donc pu tisser comme
pau support en mode on est ainsi de ti
de 10 les hommes sont plus comme sous
pli femmes sont plus comme ça on en
aimerait penser que biologiquement on
est un peu le même quand je pense que
des fois ci c'est typiquement américains
en ont on voit des différences mais est
ce que est ce que c'est biologique ou
ces identitaires ou c'est sociale soit -
le moment donné dans ma carrière j'ai
arrêté de me poser ces questions là
parce que j'avais pas la capacité
intellectuelle d'y répondre parce que je
donnais un cours dans un de mes cours à
l'université sur sexe et genre la
différence entre 6 et jean donc sexe et
les variables biologiques gens les
variables plus sociale et j'avais plein
d'étudiants qui faisait le bonhomme du
pied ou deux par jour sur l'autre les
ratures je dois je vous êtes
complètement vous avez complètement
raison qu'il parce que on s'est souvent
posé la question est-ce que ce qu'on est
en train d'observer ce sont des effets
biologiques des effets de genre et donc
j'ai formé un étudiant qui s'appelle
rappeur joey starr je vous suggère de
l'éviter parce que c'est capoter ce que
lui fait est lui ouvert le laboratoire
lgbt qu plus et stress et donc il va
étudier ça par exemple donner un exemple
bien sympa première question de robert
différences hommes femmes peu importe la
cause on la voit paré pour mieux
l'inventer la main du monde dans mon
labo les goys bon réagissez soit plus
que les faits que je le veuille ou pas
maintenant la question que rob s'est
posé ces méthodes sont en orientation
sexuelle qu'en est il des hommes
homosexuels et des femmes homosexuelles
est ce qu'on va avoir la même différence
est donc ce qui a fait et qui a demandé
à des personnes homosexuelles de venir
au la bouille et se stresser et il
manque que les hommes homosexuels
réagissent comme les femmes hétéros en
termes d'hormones de stress dont qui
réagissent pas beaucoup au stress et
celle inverse pour les femmes
homosexuelles donc ce qu'on observe ans
hier ce serait l'orientation sexuelle
plus que fait le sera fascinant c'est ce
qu'on appelle une interaction entre le
sexe et le genre
donc tu as ton sexe biologique taton
jantes les deux interagissent qui vont
modifier toutes ces écoutes c'est d'une
complexité mais ce ne sera vraiment
vraiment intéressant est celui qui est
capable de parler de soit bien mieux que
moi c'est vraiment robert qui ne fait
que ça ouvre la réflexion tout un énorme
merci des bâtiments qui vous remercie
mais attend que les gens vont vraiment
apprécié merci